i thought i'd come here and i'd be like
an instant like everyone be like oh
kawaii blonde girl
do you want to be an internet you want
to be an idol in japan just take over
the
country life really hits you like a
track
hello and welcome to another episode of
the trash taste podcast i am your host
for today
gigguk and with me are my usual co-hosts
the boys
you know who they are yeah and with me
again
as i'm hosting i have another guest
wow we have the beautiful sid snap and i
can say that
but uh yes do you want to introduce
yourself sydney hey guys
it's gigger's wife
that's that's all you want the strongest
intro i've ever heard
hey guys you didn't even say it's your
girl i was about to okay go go go go and
say
hey guys okay that's all you need to
know
you can tell she's a girl so you go by
sid snap on youtube yes okay oh my gosh
so do you want to explain to anyone who
is
unfamiliar with your content what you
kind of do okay
uh so i have a youtube channel i usually
talk about
some of the looter things on the anime
spear
nice way of putting it down
but non-christians come over if you're
feeling curious
um talk about eroge manga
eye penetration and other beautiful
beautiful stuff just doing god's word i
want to get right into it what
let's just jump right into it around the
box yeah yeah i gotta i'm just
excited to talk about this can you
explain
what the the [ __ ] of the round table is
right away please just get it out
i've heard the name
[Music]
so i saw this thing i advertised online
and it was just like this giant fleshy
it's it's this
fleshy giant roll of a bunch of cookies
there's no there's no other way to
describe it it's it's just like the
dough
and you bought it for a video to clarify
yeah one of my videos
where i'm just like sex products in
japan that are animely weird
and it's just like just a bunch of
[ __ ] of like girls like six right
six of them around and you're supposed
to like take it with the boys when you
want to have a little party
just invite the boys over for let's
let's have a
nice little little [ __ ] i remember you
told me something about it that was like
it's
in order of age yeah one of them's like
uh-huh you know because it's japan you
know
okay elementary middle school high
school
adult how how far adult do we go
grandma grandma puss
at the end it's like one of them just
so that's a great first topic i just
wanted to talk about that
i never thought to myself i need like an
item for the circle jerk
something's missing from this circle
joke oh yeah
the thing is like i've we've always
known about japan japan has like some
weird ass
toys everyone right everyone knows but
like having moved here and really like
you know living with sydney and seeing
some of the [ __ ] she has to buy for her
channel it's just like i
i thought gunpoint
i thought my faith in humanity couldn't
get lower the next week it just like
lowers every single week because i
remember
remember this one time we were in this
like dojinshi shop and she was like
looking for
weird things to buy and then we just see
this brain right
and i'm just like why are they selling a
brain there's no reason why you
a shop should be selling a brain and
then and then we pick up the box and we
turn it over
and it's just like this brain that you
can [ __ ] like stick your dick in
so it's it's a literal fleshlight that's
shaped like a brain well some people
want a brain fog
some people want a literal brain so
heavy what worries me
what worries me about the the round
table
of the you know object um is that
normally
if i wanted to [ __ ] a brain i'd probably
do that in private okay
i'm probably gonna keep that to myself
but there's someone out there who has
six homies who's like
boys i've got it and then they're all
equally [ __ ] up and they've all told
each other
how would you even position yourself
there's actually a diagram
that comes with the box of like they're
so so like this there's an anal hole
like right at the bottom
as well it's like imagine this like huge
play-doh of like
like with six [ __ ] on this plate
though right yeah yeah it looks like a
bar stool
and then there's a hole at the bottom so
how it goes is that there's a guy at the
bottom
and you put it you put it on a dick and
then like six other dicks can be [ __ ]
this this [ __ ] hole
as it's just on this guy how is this
episode of already more loot than the
shibuyaka episode
your parents are going to be watching
this so i want to know how do you go
from
uh normal human being functioning in
society
to reviewing the [ __ ] of the round
table on youtube
what's the origin story of that how do
you how do you get into that yes
voice acting online because we're in
like the same community but i
you know how did it like go from how did
you get into voice acting and then go
into
that kind of side of youtube are you
asking how everything the beginning of
my life
yeah you should draw a guess yeah yeah
all right
we're i guess like so i started out on
youtube when youtube just began i was
about 12
13. and i was a big anime nerd i was
that girl you know just like call me
yumiko kawagawa
in high school and i was like what's the
best way to be the most closest to an
anime girl that you can but
and i was just like maybe being her
voice so i tried
doing voice acting and then i grew up
and i stopped doing fandubs
and a bridge series because you were
pretty big in the like
bridging scene back in the day weren't
you i remember because
back when bridging was like at his prime
you had like team four star and then you
had
a lot of other people were trying to
emulate what team four star were doing
yeah
and it got to the point where people
started realizing
hey if we use female voice actresses we
could make our bridge series look legit
because most of bridge series were just
like dudes yeah all dudes
it would just be like the dudes uh
playing the girl characters doing their
like best falsetto or whatever it's
called
um so if you had a female voice actor
that meant you're bridgely was like
legit but have a budget the problem is
that there weren't many female voice
actresses
in the community so i remember like how
i discovered sydney was she was like one
of the five female voice actors
actresses who was just like in
everything right so that's that's how i
discovered you
like how was it back in the day for you
being like voicing in
so many different abridged series and so
many different paragraphs you were like
first generation like online voice actor
yeah i was i started when i was like 14.
i i mean back then obviously i was kind
of like around when the boom of it kind
of began obviously when people were just
like [ __ ] girls want a voice in our
[ __ ] terrible
parody
and so i like i get a lot of offers
every day because there's not many girls
who have like microphones yeah
oh i guess my me and my blue yeti
project if we have to
so it was like you know i felt like hot
[ __ ]
i mean yeah like female voice actors
were a wanted commodity
you were like like whoa so um
i it was pretty fun you know i felt like
a celebrity like what
you don't know who i am i'm in every
abridged series
you go to like walmart you're like oh
god they're looking out
oh god they're starting because i
probably know who i am
[Music]
oh jesus so so i got asked like were
there a lot of projects that you were in
that
um you may be not so proud of now like
looking back at
i think you can say without without name
without naming you can
without naming that's what you know
someone's a good voice actor if you
if they if they're like yeah man i love
everything i've been in and i'm like oh
you're [ __ ]
yeah that's i mean [ __ ] that means you
don't recognize how bad some of this
[ __ ] was
yeah no definitely there are a probably
i'd say about like a good like seventy
percent
seventy percent or be like a voice actor
yeah
maybe even close to 90 because very
rarely and this is going to sound
terrible but like
when i was in the parodies i only
laughed i'd say very like one or two
three
none of them were funny i'm sorry
[Laughter]
every every every abridger whose voice
with sydney is just like maybe i'm the
ten percent
i was like i'm the ten percent i could
be the ten percent funny right there
were you ever like cashed in here
because you okay if you were one of the
five female did you ever get like cast
in a project and then you're like cool
cool this is good and then you hear the
other voice actors and you're like how
do i get out of this
how do i how do i how do i back the [ __ ]
up of course because like back then it's
just like they're like oh you're a girl
even though you're using your like
laptop mic i've never acted before but
it's just like of course um but you know
sometimes like i was like i'm
unfortunately one of those people that's
like once i kind of offer something it's
really hard for me to say like
i'm just not gonna do it it's like it's
really hard to say no
so most of the time i just i'm like i'm
going to do the lines but i'm not going
to do it with enthusiasm
like yeah i feel like that's just the
best way to practice from what i've
heard
like i mean i'd say with a lot of things
you just got to do it even if you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you're going to suck for the longest
time and then you eventually learn how
to do it just audition just never stop
auditioning and then you'll get better
that was
definitely how it was back then it's
like even if it was all [ __ ] it's been
it's practice
yeah yeah yeah but yeah so how did you
try
like what so when did you ever stop
voice acting or is it something you just
kind of lost interest in
like i mean it kind of plays into how we
met isn't it like because we met
from his abridged series ava bridge in
case you guys couldn't guess
oh my god here we go
but um once i we started dating i
actually moved
like after we started like i moved to
england and i started going to school in
england
and i think from that point i stopped
voice acting for a good few years um
but then i came back because i was just
like you know you you said like you
think i should try and do youtube and
i'm like i don't know voice acting's not
in the same community and you're like
maybe don't do voice acting
[Music]
and then i started doing manga videos
because i really like manga
right and um i started noticing like
people tended to prefer what i talked
about some of the looter titles like it
started off with like jk haru as a sex
worker
and to like you know naval sex
of course no i i think the big
transition was when you did your video
on euphoria yeah
right i feel like god has all the
answers to these questions
he's like no sydney that's not harry
potter i was there
he was though he was like god's like
human fact checker yeah he was the one
who like actually i
i definitely wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for garn he like helped pave the
way
kind of told me what these like hey this
like might be a good thing and i'm
like i don't know and anytime i needed
advice he was there
yeah because i remember when i saw some
of your thumbnails i'm like that's not
that's not the level of clickbait from
somebody who's been doing this for
four months and i was like did you make
the thumbnails like yeah i did
i
um but definitely i think i started
getting more traction when i started
talking about because i
i'm not going to lie i like to play a
good organ you know i like
anyone does yeah we all know this man
lived off them yeah when he was 13. yeah
just played a little euphoria and little
just playing okay let's see because like
i i mean to arrogance but i never had
the balls to try before okay
okay
how did you first find out about
euphoria um
i heard somebody talk about it but i
didn't really like they didn't say
anything bad about it they just said oh
it's like kind of like a death game and
i
you know i really like horror i like
death games i have no idea what this is
by the way i'm sure there's a lot of
poop
oh okay okay we'll we'll get we'll get
into that i mean you're not wrong yeah
absolutely so what one day sydney's just
like messing about on her computer and
she just casually asked me
hey god have you heard of this uh anime
hentai called euphoria
i'm like yeah why and she's like
i'm i'm thinking about playing it i'm
like oh
okay um that's a pretty infamous game
and she
she kept she keeps asking me why why is
it infamous what's this what's so
infamous about this game it sounds like
the same energy as your mum coming
like what is
you know what sydney why not just
download it and play it and why would
you say that and see what happens
because it's already down there
you love you love this woman no it's
resulted in probably one of my favorite
twitter threads online because i told
her to document her experience
with it and so she has this twitter
thread of
like of her like fresh experience with
euphoria which we can probably pull out
because i was so certain that you were
overreacting if i'm honest
i was so certain like i've seen my fair
share of a rogue i know i've played
black
or bible black okay and like i'm like oh
is somebody just gonna like
accidentally puke or something and
everyone's just like this is disgusting
oh the moment i saw that twitter story
being started i was like oh
i was like it was one of the few twitter
threads where you can literally grab the
popcorn
and just scroll down because there has
never been a more well-documented
like journey of someone losing their
mind
because i think it was it was never the
same after you played euphoria and you
released that euphoria
video i think that was like your your
first really dive into full degeneracy
i of course i played like a rogue like
sometimes like some weird do you want to
explain what euphoria is to someone like
connor and people who don't have no idea
what euphoria is
yeah i wish i wish we could say that's
the word can we do a youtube friendly
version so we don't get completely
different
okay
but um which also appears in your phone
yeah i think essentially everything
grows that you can even think of on the
top of your head in the next three
seconds
it's in euphoria so euphoria is the kind
of game where
[Laughter]
sorry so euphoria is a game where
this one guy who suddenly starts to
realize he's a sadistic [ __ ] who
enjoys like
girls pains is stuck in a room with um
like
seven other girls and um they give him
like
acts that he has to do otherwise they
somebody dies and gets like
gets killed basically like soul yeah
essentially but like
eating [ __ ] and so like they have
essentially every weird tag
they have like diaper wearing and
[ __ ] and you have to eat the [ __ ]
out of the diaper they have
like this is a furry convention
oh my god taking your thing to another
one
my god dude this sounds too much for
youtube but i think i get a picture of
how disgusting this is a lot here
and so that defines your youtube career
unfortunately
so you made you read you watched that or
you experienced it you're like
this is it this is my magnum this is my
peak this is what we're going to follow
to be fair like i made a video because
i'm like i thought nobody else knew that
euphoria was this bad i thought they
thought that what i did i thought
everybody else thought it was like a
death game and i'm like i'm warning you
guys
and too little did i know i'm the
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] over here
so well i mean someone had to experience
it yeah
yeah i'm just taking the l for everybody
one thing i'm sure a lot of people have
been curious about is obviously like
you're a female who's like very into
hentai
but like how did you get into hentai
originally like what
opens the gate for you and what like
what what made what made it appealing to
you
to like because the general consensus is
females don't read hentai yeah exactly
right
but um i guess like it's like it's hard
to start from the beginning then yep
it's just more of like
in case you guys didn't know i grew up
or i was
born and raised in a small village in
wisconsin near milwaukee
and wouldn't you think it they're pretty
conservative
so i didn't have a sex education and i
got all of my sex education from
actually from yeah hentai
this is going like the good christian
girl
like i had no idea that like jizz was
like
looked like anything like i didn't know
like stuff came out
i was 17 when i learned that jizz
existed oh my gosh oh my
god i didn't even know what else people
don't teach you yeah no
our sex education was more of like stay
abstinent
don't do it yeah i've seen a bunch of
those right it's like you can either
teach sex education or tell them to not
just not [ __ ] and not do any of you yeah
yeah
it was we had a sex ed but it wasn't sex
ed it's more of like
but um so i actually learned i i didn't
know that
hentai really existed until i um it was
actually very similar to garn story
where i like found a random link to
bible black
uh and i downloaded it and then i saw
just like a girl like growing a dick and
i'm like can girls do that
you wouldn't know you wouldn't you
wouldn't you know
how do i grab penis like guys can jesus
can girls throw dicks
is that just the thing that my parents
have just not taught me essentially
but um so i think from there just my
interest grew because i was like well
this is the only sense
so then i just kind of dived in and
actually some of it had good stories and
it wasn't just
[ __ ] and then just life changed from
there
so what else like some early hentai that
you actually like properly enjoyed
because because as as a as like a
teenager i'm sure most guys
we had one purpose of why we like got
into hentai we didn't really care about
the plot that much
i still don't care about the plot yeah
he still doesn't but someone from your
perspective i feel would
you know have have something different
uh well definitely when i first started
like watching hentai in a rogue you know
was just to get like you know just kind
of like
the what is this warm feeling in my
pants but then
but then i started like my first real
rogue that i liked was
you made me do and um
it was just like about depression and
just like and this guy's just having sex
with these depressed girls and i'm like
oh my god
i'm having feels well my my pants are
warm
oh my god this is not gonna be monetized
no way we're so
oh my god but um there's like a million
other ways you could afraid
you didn't have
was the first one and then obviously
you know i was like once with good
stories
stories and then i kind of started going
for like the generally like hey this
isn't just
sex this is a good plot you know kind of
like one of those porns like you see
and it's like somehow one of those lines
just sticks with you yeah yeah i've
never seen a
an actual porno i'm like damn this story
is good i mean the only like quotable
porn
like horrible ones yeah yeah yeah you
didn't get my cereal
yeah i think she wants me to suck my
neck
wait i gotta i gotta ask connor have you
ever watched like a hentai
and just watched the entire run time no
skipping
no skipping just watch an entire episode
without
without
skipping hitting that button look at the
i'll look at the watch i'm like i've got
10 minutes i can watch the intro
[Music]
i got time i can watch the intro and
then i'm normally just disappointed and
like i wish i just didn't know your
personality
the characters normally i like regret
that i learned well that just means you
haven't seen the good ones yet yeah
well i think i've seen some good ones
like i
i mean i don't know what i'm like why
don't without myself right yeah because
it's like a peak of life you've got to
save it for the hentai episode
because uh i gotta because we want to do
that yeah you want to do like a hentai
team we judge each other's favorite end
times
so i'm gonna save it uh you know gotta
keep some aces in there well then while
sydney's here then what is yours like
what would you say is like the absolute
peak of like yes this is the best one
i've seen yeah to be fair i don't re or
uh
i don't watch a lot of like animated
hentai because you know once you've seen
one honestly you kind of seen them all
like it all looks the same
they're all based off the dojins though
yeah
well a lot of them are based on
variegate yeah yeah yeah and like even
the if they were based off the dojins
it was like or like hentai manga it was
just like kind of
like it doesn't keep the good [ __ ] you
know it's not as beautiful it doesn't
keep the plot
it doesn't create the plot and even the
sex scenes that they copy that are like
hot in the
dojins aren't hot in anime yeah i don't
know like
especially some dojians especially if
they're animated by queen bee
oh my god i do not talk about queen i
don't know how queen bee can take some
of the like
best doujins like s here joe dojins yeah
and make it seem like
worsely animated than the [ __ ] manga
itself there have been so many where i
like i'm
into the idea of the story i'm watching
the cut scenes and i forget i'm still
watching queen bee
start rubbing against each other and i'm
like oh some queen bee stuff i've seen
is like they they must have animated
this on like powerpoint yeah yeah
there's no animation because the the the
worst thing about queen bee
is that they're like the posters
yeah queen bee is a hentai studio quite
infamous if you watch enough hentai for
just
having the worst animation you can
imagine
if you've watched the hentai and you
thought wow this looks awfully [ __ ]
it's probably
i think queen bee was one of the first
studios that forced me to like
research hentai studios right because
normally like
hentai hentai animation isn't the same
animation isn't the greatest
but it's it's like it's it's possible
but queen bee was so bad that it forced
me
to have to google search why does these
certain hentais look this bad
oh okay it's because the same it's
because the same studios are animating
it
but yeah going back to you so what are
some hentais you would like probably
recommend not anime then
you're gonna we're gonna put you on yeah
are we gonna [ __ ] go down there okay
so yeah we're gonna go down the raft
we've already like
we've already gone down we've already
fallen down get close to the microphone
you're really far away i can see on the
audio
okay this episode is sponsored by
bandai spirits and today they brought us
the upcoming that time i got
reincarnated as a slime
van pristo box this is a hefty boy
that's a big
thick that's a thick boy that is
oh baby what's in the box connor what's
what's
in the box what open the box
what's in the box i'm glad you asked
what's in the box gone because i don't
know yet so should we find out what's in
the box together what's in the box
god stop
let me feel that it's actually like
really soft oh okay okay very nice
oh so this is the rimmer uh large plush
uh it's
20 centimeters or 7.9 inches and it
feels great in your hand you put it on
your head you can put it on your
shoulder you can put it anywhere look at
this this is like this is like
how can you feel stressed holding this
and there's also this what is this jerry
oh that is the mascot plush special
color version which is another
exclusive item for this band presto box
it's gonna ask a little keychain as well
so you can take it onto something it is
a keychain
oh look look at look at this beauty i
just i just got i just got a [ __ ] out of
this beauty look at that
oh my god oh that looks similar to the
one that we have
looking cleanest yeah this one is the uh
exq figure special color version and
this also is an exclusive item too
that base is so cool that is really cool
the colors but wait
there's more we're not done here there
is two key chains i'm seeing in here am
i reading this right yeah there's two
features two keychains right here two
rubber keychains
we have a rubber keychain of a cool
looking rimrou and slime together
and another keychain with rimro with
shizu's mask
that is useless mask yeah i totally
didn't see that yes
that's cool and there's one more item in
here gentlemen
that's super cute that's so cute i like
how it like
like flushes yeah yeah yeah it's
certainly it's like the round shape
of the slime yeah but that's uh
exclusive yeah it's a cute little
slime mug right here oh i like this
shape actually
and the value of all of this is 60 usd
but the best part is gentlemen it's only
29.99
only 29.99 half price i know
29.99
very excited about this can't believe it
so some of these products can only be
sold in japan so you can't get it in
north america
at all so if you want to get your hands
on this special box go to premium bander
usa or click the link in the description
below and this box is only available
until november 24th 2020 so get your
hands on it quick
again thank you very much to bandai
spirits for sponsoring us today
back to the video well obviously if
we're gonna go down this route
i honestly prefer if i'm going to be
reading hentai
or like hentai dojins or hentai manga
like so i guess what's your go-to tag
penetration oh definitely able
penetration
it depends on the day sometimes i'm
looking for like virginity
and then sometimes i'm just like what's
the most
skull [ __ ] totally
i want to see those jizz i want a
position of power being
abused through the eye socket
but yeah do you have any like specific
titles that you would recommend
obviously anything by
pochi which is a hentai manga artist and
she's also
having an anime being released it was
delayed yeah it was supposed to come out
last season yeah um she obviously at the
anime getting you know animated for
she's the artist who did the
art for the milf isekai
but it's not going to be the hentai
version of that it's going to be the one
yeah so like the tan girl
no no that's now you're talking about
nanashi who did uh
nagatoro yeah on twitter all the time
yeah
she's also a hentai artist i see a lot
of that if i'm completely honest i
always like to go to
series that are like of characters that
are like in the games i'm playing like i
like playing like harvest moon and rune
factory and sometimes i like to see the
characters i get to marry have sex with
my character
well i guess that's just like the i
guess that's just like the appeal of the
gingers
i've never played a video game and
thought man [ __ ] i just want to see
zefroff just take a huge
dude
you look that [ __ ] up there's probably
thousands of dollars i don't know
because they're not getting
do you guys remember the very first
dojinshi that you ever read or like
discover you've never read a digit
no okay connor's told me that he can't
get off to drawn paul no
what it's like a [ __ ] just i i have
more chance like [ __ ] masturbating to
like
uh money like the queen
it's doing the same thing for me like
you know what i mean like i need some
[ __ ] movement going on
so juni is is it the movement is it the
noise literally masturbating the same
way they did in like 1800s when the
camera was like
like oh god my my wife that i haven't
seen in 40 years because i went to the
war
i'm going to bust off did you never like
look at like
the [ __ ] playboy magazines and think
like damn that's hot yeah i did but then
i realized like
moving porn was also an option and then
how can you go back
it's like it's like the episode of south
park where like they they lose internet
and then they take turns on like the pc
masturbating to pawn
i guess i guess i guess it's because for
me like i remember
the very first time i discovered the
jinchis were a thing
where yeah you know you you'd watch the
you you'd watch these anime
and you'd be like you know this this
this anime girl's like kind of hot
but of course because it's an officially
licensed product you don't get to see
any porn of that i've never felt that
way about anime i've never seen anime
being like man i want to see these
characters get [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
really no no no even not even as like a
kid but have you never had like a
childhood crush
on like a girl i or but i've never like
wanted to like
because to me it feels like i don't know
this is weird but like
i i like it when my like porn is
separated from the stuff i enjoy
you know what i mean no i can't i want
it completely isolated i get that
okay so i can cut that [ __ ] off and
nothing in my life changes right like
what's that like no nut challenge we
start levitating after a month
like if i want to cut that [ __ ] out it's
not gonna affect like you know if i'm
looking at me casa porn every week
and then i'm gonna be watching attack on
titan i'm gonna be like damn
i've seen her get digged down you know
what i mean like i
i no i get that though because like i
don't read doujins of
series that i like right because you
want to only read really i read dozens
of series i actually don't like
but like the characters are hot and you
don't like them like yeah because like i
don't because i don't care because i get
that the characters are good looking but
i don't care enough about their
personality to see them get digged yeah
i would never want to read you know what
i
mean
from a show that i i like enjoy i don't
know
so like my favorite i'm i'm am i the am
i the weird one here no no no there's a
lot of people who are like i love this
character
therefore i want to see them get kicked
but i don't follow it
okay all right i'm going to watch
because that's why like that's why like
i [ __ ] love like sword online or emo
like love life
because i don't care about these
characters enough though but they're all
good-looking characters i'm like all
right
that's cool when you like watch a porno
i don't want to be personally invested
in their lives i'm watching a porno i
like watching
no i want like being personally involved
this is going to sound
this is going to sound so [ __ ] intel
right now but
being being at your relationship being
being invested in porn
being invested in porn just like
elevates it to like
like newer heights that's that's why i
like porn
that's like that's why i like plot with
my porn but at the end of the day i feel
like you're putting up more barriers
for like entry to have a good just wank
at the end
you know what i mean but that wake is
worth it though
it's like the best one you're gonna get
no because i get i
if i watch a doge you know i read a
dozen of a character that i really like
or series i really like
the next time i have anything to do with
that series in the back of my mind i'm
just like yeah i'm thinking about it and
it completely puts me out of the
experience and
how also is that like why do you want to
put work on yourself by reading and
having to imagine the rest you know what
i mean because
because you have to imagine the rest
it's drawn out it's not every single
like little frame in your mind
that just means you've read [ __ ] yeah i
know i've never i've never read any
i don't know like it's it's like it's
that's like saying is is all sex the
same to you
well okay why do you okay this could get
way too deep i don't
really want to god
what the same the same reason why anyone
does the
time right i am 90 of the time i just do
it because i got nothing better going on
i'll be honest with you i got like 10
minutes to kill i don't want to do the
tasks that i've set myself like i got to
make this thumbnail i don't want to do
it well i guess so
most people so you just do it to waste
time yeah most people you know like
walk or clean it
kind of like whatever i got five minutes
i've got five minutes free one i want to
have a quick like uh danger whack or
whatever it's free right now
but no like it's you know like most
people the the act of doing it is a
physically pleasurable for me i just
feel like it's right it cleans my mind
i don't know i feel like it's like a
reset like a save it's like you've gone
to the pokemon
you're talking like a [ __ ] monk now
for some reason
you're like i feel i feel clean i feel
cleansed
you go in your bedroom you know if it's
midday you feel dirty that you're gonna
like do it and then you're like all
right and then you do it then you come
out like levitating like
it's like hard resetting a concert i'm
ready for a day yeah yeah
it's like i couldn't just like reset the
game like in the game or i could turn
off
the console back on you've got like 20
chrome tabs open the shit's
really slow you're like [ __ ] i'll
just restart the pc like that's what
it's like
yeah i mean you just close the tabs
sometimes it's still not so laggy you
know and you're just like [ __ ]
restart it
i mean i would have to ask so like
you've never really cared about
you you never cared about it i know you
got now yeah yeah well that's that's
that's
why i guess i i would understand because
i felt exactly the same and then
i you know i remember the first time i
read the digi about characters
not not characters i cared about but i
guess characters i was like
invested in maybe like getting together
because
okay i'm guessing neither of you or
neither of anyone here went through like
the fan fiction phase
no not really
have you i went through the harvest moon
fan fiction
what you and the other three people out
there because i
because there would be times when i
would like be watching an anime and i'd
be like man i really want this couple to
get together i'd be really
i'm i'm i'm i'm showing my i'm showing a
new side of my degeneracy
but yeah i i i remember the first time
was during like haram anime and harry
manga where
there would be this like there like
obviously there would be a winning girl
i'd be like but what would happen if the
other girl won
what would happen if the other girl won
i have to agree with that
do you not feel like you're like wasting
time why why why why why
why because i've exactly i've had that
exact thing where it's like
when because like when i was like in uh
like teenage years i was like heavily
invested in like to love her
yeah and i [ __ ] love that but like at
the time i was reading it there wasn't
like a clear winner but there were lots
of potential winners
yeah i want to know i just wanted what
if
if he got with this girl yeah what would
it be like because because because what
got me into the genji's is that there
are so many anime with like this
romantic subplot
that goes [ __ ] nowhere yeah right and
i i just
i just want to see the ending of that
sublime
that's on the show not being satisfying
but to me it's like
i wouldn't want a story by an author to
then just be
someone's like i got it from here like
you know what i mean like to me that's
weird
like that's why i've never been able to
like get my head around fan fiction
why would you want someone else to write
the story that like because someone else
would only really know
because if you don't have if you can't
get the satisfaction from the official
product
you you just have to search that out
somewhere else it's not like i'm just
like fine with it
having that satisfaction i don't want to
be bothered to imagine them myself
therefore
for example for example if there was say
i'm going to bring it up again but if
there was like domestic girlfriends
dojinshi's
i don't need that [ __ ] because they
[ __ ] [ __ ] in this
in like the actual series so like why
why would i need that fanfiction
i've never watched an anime and been
like damn i really need to know what
would happen
based on a third party's opinion of what
could happen
if x person got you know what i mean
that sounds weird to me i don't know it
doesn't make sense does it not
am i a crazy guy here i think i think
we're both the crazy ones here
we're both on like two ends of the
extreme where i sometimes
i i it's like an itch that i can't
scratch where like if if there's a
series where i know
i'm never gonna see these people get
together or this this author's never
gonna finish it the way
that i would like to finish it that my
girl that i want to win is not gonna win
that i'm gonna search out the best way
possible of how to itch that scratch
and it's not just that jin she's like
yeah scratch that yeah
scratch that edge i kind of relate it a
little bit i remember when i watched
code gios
first time i was like why didn't lelouch
ever like [ __ ] c2 yeah
i wanted him to do it because i'm like
homie just yeah because you're taking
over the world let a little stress out
let your hair down
order some pizza and kick back because
like because like here's the thing
here's the thing right here's the thing
i
i can't read a doujinshi for like every
series there are certain series that i
think
i [ __ ] made for the jin cheese and
then i see like one piece though jinxies
and i'm like
why would anyone want to get off of this
that's they're not that that doesn't
seem very
like that's weird let me pick up the
error that doesn't seem very
nakama of these guys i'm gonna say
someone makes sense right
because there's so much sexual change
i don't know i just i i can't get my
head around it maybe someday i will but
like
i feel like you just need to see the
good ones yeah you just need to grow a
bit i
i actually actually remember this whole
podcast is connor you just need to try
the good one
once you find the perfect tag yeah
that's that's it it's game over
yeah yeah this is why i don't get into
any more gadgets i just feel like i'm
going to lose more time and i don't want
to waste any more well you're using that
time to jack off anyway so it's like
i spent 10 minutes max jacking off yeah
well you can spend that 10 minutes
reading
no that's too much time because you've
got to go through
find one that you want and i bet you
probably have that thing as well where
it's like netflix where you're like [ __ ]
which one do i want
okay okay here's here's the thing most
of the time when i discover a good
hentai
it's by complete accident how are you
finding this because like normally i'm
just like skip skip skip and i'm like
skip on what huh button on like the on
like the random page or like i find like
just a don't
cover anyone yeah yeah and sometimes i
like i like give it like five minutes if
it's like a anime but if it's like i i'm
less likely to give it a chance if it's
an anime because with like dojinshi's
you can just you can read way faster you
know it's like it's like
it's like one on youtube you hear that
1.5 speed button when you're just like i
want to see what happens when i can't be
bothered to like hear everything
at this exact place do you ever just
like you just can't find a good one
so you're just like [ __ ] it i'll just
i'll just get off to one of them i just
try to do it because like this is taking
too long
uh no because i know how to find the
good ones yeah but sometimes i go
it comes like a complete accident where
i start reading i'm like this uh this
has got some character development on
there like
maybe i'll give it a shot like let's go
over here for a second no no
there's some character development okay
okay like if they don't if there's like
if there's like ten pages uh if the ten
first pages if the ten first pages go by
and there's no [ __ ]
you know the author has given thought
into the story of this dojin man
you know what i'm talking about joe you
know what i'm talking about don't
pretend like you're unfortunately doing
this
that's that's that's always the big tell
when when it doesn't start off by just
[ __ ] straight away
then you know there's a chance that this
guy actually cares yeah they actually
care
and then i don't know being invested in
a story
like that's that's kind of how i got
into you know nozakiana and a lot of
other titles that
have like off-course stuff yeah like the
soft-core stuff that
have sex in them but also you know have
a really good plot that you can get
emotionally invested in have you ever
gotten too
anime through the dojins yes have you
what have you ever gotten into an anime
yeah because you saw a dojin
absolutely even though you haven't seen
the animated apps are [ __ ] which
which one
okay i remember i actually read code yes
dogens before i watched it
i'm not that degenerate
no no um it's hard for me because again
the only dojins i read that are parodies
of anime are the ones
are the anime series that i didn't enjoy
so satiate that like space
i read the dozens for it well i don't
know if there is one that
was the opposite i'm sure there is but
they're probably just like not
they're like no no yeah they're not
worthy series right but i guess that's
that's like the difference between just
you know
have having a quick 10 minute jack off
session to
my god this is like the most degenerate
goddamn podcast
you're watching this with your parents
no one talks about this [ __ ] but we all
experience this and no one wants to talk
about it i don't give a [ __ ]
everyone wanks let's be honest that's 20
20. everybody wins everyone wanks dude
put that on the shirt
make that a song make it a song
everybody watch
so i got to ask what is the most messed
up one that you would say
that you'd be like it's hard actually
actually
that's sorry because obviously some of
them do try to be really [ __ ] up and
it's just like kind of comes off as like
cringy like oh my god
you're [ __ ] not girls intestines like
come on like you're just trying too hard
yeah
um but some of them are just like oh
i didn't know you could do that because
because there's an entire genre for that
right
yeah it's just like that's something
that i even i don't want to touch me i
don't
i don't i don't like it like i've been
trying to dive into that side of things
just because
no one else wants to yeah so i'm just
like how bad for good reason for good
good reason how bad could it be i'm like
the the little that i've seen i'm just
like
i understand now yes this is bad no this
is something where
like if if i see something like error
guru i have to like completely separate
myself
from like that work and just view it as
like a piece of like
i am soft as a pillow whenever i was
like no i don't know how i'm i'm open to
a lot of like different sexual things
like you know
different fetishes that you know yeah
aragora though if you're into that [ __ ]
don't come here don't come near me i
don't even think that like incognito
mode can save you
no there was a okay so i was also trying
to get into eroguto probably trying to
take a
make a video on it so i in japan when i
was at a
dodgy store they had like these
magazines that are actually i didn't
know until later were kite famous for
guru which is called
irogurus yeah yeah and uh do you know
them yeah yeah yeah and
um i read one and of course it's in
japanese so i didn't fully
understand everything but i will say uh
the dead baby stuff is not my favorite
i don't think we need to go any further
than that
yeah [ __ ] probably best to wait for
either me or sydney to make a video
if we eventually get there but um no but
i totally get what you mean like some
some like doujins that are just like
trying to be way too edgy or just like
come on we know you're trying but then
there are the
actually [ __ ] up stuff like
metamorphosis for example right
like i i reckon like if there was one
i'd still say that's my favorite doujin
even though it completely [ __ ] me up
the first time i read it it's your
favorite
yeah it's my favorite because it's my
favorite because like
because i don't know like i i like a lot
of stories that are
quite depressing where like you you
watch a character go
sad wank or what no no no because that's
the thing
it was it was like an extra existential
one yeah
why am i here
no but like metamorphosis was the first
time where i was like i was prepared to
go in for a wank but then i
had to let go and be like okay hold on
zipper going up yeah
zipper going up because i i'm soft right
now
but but for a good reason right because
it's like that because that story
is like i mean i'm sure sydney can vouch
for this or whoever has read metaphor
morphs this can vouch for this but it's
like
it go it's a dojin but there it goes
beyond a dozen
you know yeah like how do you find it
i definitely when i first because when i
first heard of it i was actually i think
from aki's video when she made a video
just saying like oh it's really messed
up and i'm like
okay i think i've been around the block
but no i definitely wasn't expecting
like
majority because i also i'm a big fan of
depressing things
i'm a big fan of depression i love the
work it does and um
so when i yeah no uh so when all that
started happening when you know she
graduated
and all that yeah you know we won't go
into detail
yeah i was definitely sat once i
finished i just sat looking at
like the ceiling on the bed just like
where am i what did i do
what did i do to deserve being here
right now what did i do wrong in my life
what i think about metamorphosis it's
likely a yasmi pinpoint of hentai
it is you know what i mean straight up
is and i think that's why i love it
because i love oysters
jesus christ no because like because uh
because i did i
i interviewed shin noel the creator of
metamorphosis and uh i asked him about i
obviously had to ask him about that
right and yeah he said it in a really
cool way which is like
i wrote that story not to give this
entire shock value of like
i wrote a messed up dozen but because
but because he was raised in america
he's like i've seen so many people whose
lives
end up like this and i wanted to show it
not to like
fetishize it so much but more so to show
off like
this can happen to people yeah and if
you find this like
hot or attractive then there's kind of
something wrong with you i'm i'm not
showing it as a type of fetish i'm
showing it as like
he's basically he's like i'm throwing
out a message right
it's about it's about sending a message
hentai is
art that's what i'm trying to say he he
gave the hentai it's like i wrote that
because i wanted to show it off in an
artistic way and for the first time i
was like
you know what that didn't sound
pretentious wow
you're one of the first people who are
like okay i totally get it because
because i was the same thing when i read
it i was like is this just edgy
or am i thinking about this like way too
artistically but then when you finish
reading you're like
okay no it is actually quite artistic
yeah yeah definitely
you should read it yeah which is which
is like how long is it
uh it's like a hundred and something
yeah yeah it's like
like yeah
yeah because the thing is the thing i've
been wondering recently is that we
hentai has become this like buzz word
right where we use it to describe it
we use like it just to describe anything
that kind of involves like titty or sex
nowadays but
like do you feel like there's a
difference between just hentai
like like porn and like erotica with
like
good like things that have good plots
but also just happen to have sex
yeah yeah absolutely because i think the
whole hentai's hentai's art thing that's
you know
that we kind of promote is that it's
it's it's not so much that we think that
this is like jack off material we just
think that
just because it has sex in it doesn't
necessarily mean that this is just
you know porn you know that's you guys
not me
well i mean you know like that like it's
like why why does like a lot of like
artistic film use
sex as like a waiter oh yeah that's fine
i'm not gonna like bust out my dick in
the cinema when i see a sex scene yeah
yeah
but i think the whole like hentai is
awesome yeah yeah stems from like
oh it's got titties in it therefore it's
degenerate the only way the way that i
judge it
is if i type in free hentai and the
website
like you know has like 10 pop-ups i'm
like this is porn
oh yeah my dad this is porn if if
there's not at least five pop-ups it's
probably not porn
yeah right like i'm not going to like
play [ __ ] [ __ ] wars and be like oh
this is like
yes i love i love the artistic
innovation i feel like if anything it's
just like the
images they get shared around on twitter
most the time they're just artists just
drawing like you know just
stills or something or whatever like
just hot i like those those are nice
those are yeah
like i would never like to get on the
train and get like a chub
at seeing like a twitter art like of
like a sexual oh no no no but it's like
i'm like nice
but i mean you guys would right because
you read your doujins i mean just a
picture wouldn't be enough
yeah yeah i don't know it takes more
than that
i don't crack
let me just like i'm just like next to
the train on joey at rush hour i'm like
joey
i can feel it stop stop watching him you
see me on a pack train just like liking
hentai on my twitter like
i need the semen bank of a [ __ ] bull
if i which like if like if i were to
jack off every time i saw a lead on my
twitter timeline
jesus christ cause there were there's so
many loots in your timeline
you'd be jacking off every like every
other [ __ ] second
basically there's got to be a challenge
right it's like you see a nude on
twitter you got a jackal
you have to finish everything it's like
the opposite of no nothing
only not nervous
i like how this conversation completely
just delved
we should go back to youtube stuff and
sydney's origin story
we'll save for the hentai episode we can
talk about this forever yeah that's like
a straight hour
like is hentai really aren't no
this is the most civilized discussion
we've had on trash days
i remember when we were discussing one
time and then me and gant were there
and it was you and then i think you were
like no people come for me from like my
super serious anime takes
i looked at gone i'm like what no you
said because
you're like oh people come to you
because they like your personality no
but they want my recommendations yeah
they were like and i looked at god i'm
like
no back me up man back me up a year and
a half ago yeah yeah yeah that's what
you were like i think you were still
getting this
i was getting the hang of it yeah but
even then i felt that your videos that
were recommending stuff it was still
like
people came for your personality not for
the recommendations yeah yeah
recommendations died yeah like five
years ago
nobody actually seeks recommendations on
youtube no no no no and i i want to just
be entertained for 10 minutes so i don't
think about my day yeah i mean if the
recommendation comes as like a
plus you know what i mean yeah to
whatever the personality who is
presenting it
if i'm honest i mean i personally i
don't think i'm
anything you can't get anywhere
personality-wise but i
mean don't come i don't want i'm not a
singer but i just want to say i wasn't
going to do it
way to assume
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you guys
no but then um that's why i guess like
in a way i
don't think anyone who starts youtube
right away in the first like year thinks
of themselves as a personality like they
think like
oh i'm just doing stuff about anime yeah
it's not about me i mean it's it's
something you definitely grow into yeah
and
i don't i can't remember how long it's
it took me um
because it took me forever cindy you've
been doing youtube for like
how long now years old oh my god you're
a youtube child yeah
with this kind of content obviously with
this kind of content yeah uh about
two years two and a half years something
like that like how's your journey been
in that two years like growing honestly
i think i've started to accept
you know it's like kind of like at first
initially i'm like i don't deserve this
it doesn't feel like i've done anything
imposter syndrome yeah
kind of like in part up until recently i
had really bad dude
i still get impossible like why are
people even like subscribing to me like
i'm just like really loud talking about
titty like i just say titty every like
50 times in one minute
and but i guess recently i guess i'm
just starting to say like maybe i'm not
such a piece of [ __ ]
self-confidence i think i think everyone
feels impostor
yeah yeah i feel like when another big
creator that like you maybe respect is
like yo i love your stuff you're like
oh my god yeah yeah facebook [ __ ]
tyler there's like oh i love like i like
your videos i'm like
stop trying to suck my dick no you don't
i i remember i had a
remember who it was i got a dm from
somebody like i like your videos and i
was
i was going to reply but i was thinking
about it i was just panicking i'm like
are they [ __ ] with me
are they like are they joking are they
poking fun at me
it's always from that one youtuber that
you'd never thought you'd yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
why why are you on my channel like i
[ __ ] love your videos man you're like
you're lying every time i hear a
compliment my first reaction is just
why are you lying to me
no by being british i just assume
they're being sarcastic it's like
where's the punchline
just tell me the punch line now just get
it over with i don't want to hear the
rest
please say psych thank you bookwalker
for sponsoring this segment of the video
did you know that it is bookwalker's
fifth anniversary this october
wow thank you happy birthday to daddy
book walker
so we're just going to take 10 minutes
we'll quickly talk about some of our
favorite manga on boardwalker
uh as they're sponsoring we're just
going to do a 10 minute segment where we
talk about manga who doesn't love manga
right
losers you're not my favorite fuckboy
are you gonna do it there's this man
finna do it you know what my favorite
manga or bookwalker is
also has an audiobook counterpart
it's one of the best-selling books on
audio but [ __ ]
it's you are my princess audiobook by
you know c doggy i think in the credits
who's that wow
who is that right who's that up and
coming
is is this you
is this you who's mans
if i haven't shielded enough already
yeah whatever i'm just you know
go for it just buy it you know kidding
me
[ __ ] buy it the critics say it's good
and it's got five star rating on book
walker really
yeah he had a four and a half at one
point i watched that [ __ ] like a hawk
who gave it a four star
it's five now though so everything's
been fixed so i i got mailing
i right i did i didn't i did i did i
actually went back up on the turn i'm
checking why am i so vain
all right what's your favorite mangrove
milkwalker boys or visual novel as i
think that's some of the most popular
you mean light novel you can't get
visuals
they also sell light novels as well as
manga and i believe that some of the
most popular stuff on there
um as i don't really know where else you
can buy lightning you can't really buy
light novels
legally yeah in any other website from
my understanding at least
so support the industry yeah yeah it's
it's it's been a great place to
read light novels in there i've that's
where i read the uh
um my favorite one which i forgot the
name i did actually forget the name of
it
i feel like i get a glimpse into what
animes are going to become because
normally the most popular light novels i
see
that's an anime yes i go into i go into
bulk awkward and i see like the most
popular live novel
that i don't know the name of and i'm
like that's going to be an anime soon
yeah and it usually happens yeah it
always happens
not a light novel mango like glena
[ __ ] i don't know yeah i remember that
was big on both walker and then it got
turned into an anime and i was like oh i
know that
that's the one with that because i saw
it on book walkers thank you
quarter if i can give us a sweet boy
recommendation also i just want to say
that you said boys but i'm also a female
so
boys and girls everyone is a boy
everyone's a boy everyone's a boy so
sydney what's your favorite manga slash
light love one book watching
there's just too much to pick from garn
i actually need to go to like the
bookwalk website just to refresh myself
if you actually looked at my bookwalker
account it's like all yowie
of course because most the time i buy it
for the videos but i actually have
bought some like unironically like tan
dance i've bought all of 10 dads
there's only five volumes and it's
actually like a really [ __ ] good
uh yowie
imagine like a shonen levels of hype but
with ballroom dancing and it's hella
spicy like it's actually pretty good
yeah i mean i'm gonna shout out the
index series which i've actually read
light novels on that
but love the anime yeah so if if you are
unsatisfied or confused by season three
please please read the light novel of
book walker on book walker because
that's like one of the best arcs in
index before like pre-new testament but
i'm not going to end get into that but
yeah
please read the line testament yeah
i could give a good recommendation if
you're feeling depressed
maybe and want to feel more depressed
okay i thought i was going somewhere
else then
i would say akunohana is not a bad shout
out that's a really good monkey exactly
what is it about that's a really good
flowers of evil it's a really good mom
yeah
they have an anime of it but it's just
it's not really an anime it's like kind
of like
what happens so this guy oh he kind of
just slipped out how everybody kind of
sucks in reality there
that's the description that's basically
yeah it's not
it's literally it's literally just about
a dude who
just gets himself into a really shitty
situation that he can't get out of and
then he just realizes man
humans [ __ ] suck yeah essentially
it's like he tries to not be
normal when he's handling the situation
he doesn't want to be as seen as
somebody that can be described or like
scene of like when they're describing
him like something that can be sung as
cliche but he's actually
the most cliche [ __ ] out there
so humans may suck but thank god book
walker's collection
of amazing manga and light novels you
don't have to deal with humans because
you can just go on bulk orchestra
exactly they also have attack on titan
on there which uh if you want to keep
black butler as well if you're wondering
i think i've heard of that one actually
yeah i made it one or two videos on it
do you wanna ever know what it's like to
be a prostitute in other world jk haru
is a sex worker [ __ ] go
george do you want to explain that one
yeah i feel like i said a lot of words
that i feel like need explaining that i
mean it's kind of in the description of
the title it's literally jk haru is a
sex worker in another world
how does that's easy like into species
reviews but like the other way around
yeah like she's the prostitute
oh yeah is that like i've legitimately
heard good things about this
from like several years it's actually
very well written um it's very saucy it
makes me blush when i had to read it
with like aliens or something so like
select other people so like what's
what's like the real hook for that
series which is essentially just kind of
like there's a lot of like little mini
twists in there i'm not gonna give the
spoilers because
go read it yourselves but essentially
like if you wanna know it's like being a
sex worker in another world
you can't do it i feel like i feel like
i can't relate to either of those
yeah maybe maybe i can relate to being a
sex toy
i've never thought to myself i want to
go to another world nor have i thought
to myself i want to be a broadcaster
one liner novel series i want to
recommend because it just uh finished as
obviously the anime just finished and
the light novel just finished is origami
instead of watch uh yeah as always no
actually i
i would recommend the anime as well but
if you want to get like a full glimpse
into
like the characters and everything
because that's the selling point and
that's a light novel
yeah that's a line all so it's
originally a light novel series uh it
just finished as of recently i think it
has
14 volumes it's chunky
it's a chunky boy it's a chunky boy um
but i haven't read it all yet
but i kind of read up to like volume six
or seven around when like season two of
the anime finished
and it is really [ __ ] good like that
that it almost
it almost exceeds light novel quality
it's almost like just a regular standard
book because the characters are just
so well written and it's a lot like
akunohana where it's about you know just
how
shitty humans can be and you know some
dude just trying to that's me
yeah it's just a really it's a really
just relatable story of how
one guy is just trying to fit into
society but he just does not like how
society runs he just doesn't like how
you know the whole social hierarchy of
high school is you know
constructed and everything and he's like
nah [ __ ] that [ __ ] like
i'm not gonna conform i'm not gonna
conform to the machine
yeah yeah i'm gonna be my own thing but
then he realized the difficulties of
being his own thing and how
difficult it is to i guess trust humans
it's probably the best way to say it
it's a really good read i would
recommend it trust you
trust me why does this sound so alien we
do not trust the humans
no honestly like the the the like
protagonist
like hachiman is probably one of the
most interesting protagonists i've ever
seen in an anime or i mean he's one of
the most iconic animes and
uh iconic characters in light novels
yeah absolutely yeah
okay he's just so completely different
he's almost like a deconstruction of a
protagonist
okay yeah so it's really interesting if
you want something a little different i
i would recommend audio thank god i can
read it
differently you said different right
you said i've ruined the word different
for myself every time i hear the word
different now
i've read a lot of light novels but this
one just strikes comparatively like it
is
it it does hit different yeah so i
recommend it and thank god you can read
it on board
can you read all of them on bookwalker
yeah
[Music]
there's a lot of them go read on vocals
i really need to just check they also
have
the yowie called public sex which is uh
that's exactly what you think it is it
speaks for itself doesn't it
let's read your public sex yowie honey
sorry
i'm trying okay 12. so almost all of
them you can read almost all
authoritative on bulk walker
so go check it out do i really want to
recommend domestic girlfriend
again no you don't have to it's okay
so to tell you a bit more about bulk
walker bookwalker's katakawa's official
bookstore and app for digital manga and
light novels
they currently have over 15 000 english
ebooks with new titles releasing every
single week unlike other digital e-book
platforms bulk walker was made
especially for otakus like you guys
so they offer exclusive digital bonus
items like illustrations wallpapers and
short stories
all the time so it's best to check book
walker constantly if you're interested
in those you can read all the ebooks and
manga you purchased on their website or
on their dedicated app
where now they have both vertical
strolling and horizontal scrolling
oh look at look at that called
innovation look at how sexy that is but
yeah it is book walker global's fifth
anniversary celebration and to celebrate
you can get up to 50
coin back plus earn up to 30 000 extra
coins and if you know anything about
book walker you would know that's a
goddamn deal for those of you who don't
know
coins are their in-store currency that
you get when you purchase anything
yeah it's like a point system yeah yeah
loyalty system thank you very much to
bookwalker for sponsoring this episode
back to the video knowing you personally
i feel that
a lot of your lack of confidence stemmed
from
a certain event you had with another
internet personality
namely leafy like i've already explained
the bad
like the overall story from my
perspective but what was it like for you
like being in one of his videos and
being called out by him
uh well obviously that plays a large
part as well and like my lack of
confidence also i just don't think i'm a
very confident person
but with the leafy thing how did it all
start like what was the like how did you
when did when did you make that video
and then
i made that video actually because i you
know how obviously i used to be that
predictable
kind of weeby cringe girl up until i
think the first time i went to japan
right and um then i came back from japan
and looked at myself i'm like what the
[ __ ] was wrong with me
and that's when i made that video kind
of as like oh my god like people like
this exhibit
poking fun yeah it was kind of like a
satire it was too good though
you understood your core audience way
too well
when i first saw that i thought it was
legit yeah yeah um but
and then like this one creepy guy kept
re-uploading in
like he kept uploading to 4chan and
obviously yeah and then i deleted it
when i was like 17 because i was like i
don't want
to say how long was it up before you
deleted it about a day and
a day like a few days maybe but not it
was not up long
but it just like blew up straight away
no and then um a few years later
like i haven't been doing youtube in a
bit i was just like still like in
england
and then i get this notification from
this girl uh that i knew and
like who kind of like goes on for a
chance like that
um and she said hey this video is this
video of you and it was
me obviously it was a video um and it
had about 60 000 views and i was like
initially i was pretty like embarrassed
i didn't feel good like to me at 60 000
views at that time
yeah and then i kind of like felt pretty
shitty about that but then not even a
week later
i wake up in the middle of the night to
my phone just constantly vibrating with
all of these messages from people i went
to high school with people i met maybe
once or twice
all on facebook all on you know skye
twitter just
everywhere of like hey you're in a leafy
video and you're pretty cringe and
this is like at the peak of leafy yeah
this is actually his most viewed video
ever
is it actually really [ __ ] how many
views does it have uh it had
last time i checked like 20 million
something like that
it was a lie and um just and it sucked
because i
woke up to hundreds of emails of people
telling me to kill myself
and this lasted for months yeah because
i i remember
every time like every because how the
ball kept rolling
was that every time like the comments
would start to die down
there would be another cringe
compilation and it was the cringe
compilations that kept this going on for
so long because it appeared in the leafy
video which was just like which just lit
the [ __ ] fire yeah
and then he got you got all the leafy
fans and then as soon as like like we
we you basically hot hell holed up in
like a bunker and just like
kept away from the internet and as soon
as you like came out another cringe
compilation would
come out and then i'd be getting i still
even to this day people
i know message me like with the video
like hey i just saw you in a cringe
compilation and kind of like
slightly make fun of me and obviously it
doesn't feel initially for years like of
course like i
i like it was awful like i didn't touch
my phone i would cry a lot i went
through a pretty bad period not gonna
lie like i was pretty
it was awful and no amount of words or
like any
kind of emotion i could show you now
could show you how
terrible it kind of was oh i mean just
imagining it is just
[ __ ] horrible yeah no it was terrible
because i i can't imagine
it gets the point where people i knew
from like my hometown people who like
didn't know about like anime and stuff
like i think that was the point
when i remember it like really hit you
that man this has gone really far when
you're
you're high school friends person
because like that's 20 million views on
one video but on all those
compilations those like yeah it could
easily be up to like 100 million
exactly and yeah yeah uh but [ __ ]
people
obviously talking about it now like it
doesn't feel great but i think
i've of course it's been so long i've
accepted it you know when people say
like oh you're really like you're saying
salt i'll be like dude like
who the [ __ ] are you like i don't give a
[ __ ] i mean i think the fact that you've
managed to like
live through that and still being like i
still want to like stay on the internet
i think it's
pretty [ __ ] convenient i
i mean i don't blame you like i think
anybody would be like no never going on
i mean it took a lot of convincing to
try to get sydney back on the internet
and it was it was something where i i
knew
that sydney had a personality that could
like succeed on youtube but just
it was just trying to convince her that
hey just ignore all these comments that
you've been hearing over the past
of the haters yeah [ __ ] the haters [ __ ]
the haters [ __ ] they hate comments
um and just like just just be you
because i don't like one thing i can
appreciate about
sydney is that she doesn't know how to
be anyone but herself
like what you see is like what you get
so like
that that like can also backfire
sometimes where
you know people don't know where like
people like
you know people think you know where
like the cringe compilation and stuff
like that
yeah but you know you're you're where
you are now and i think you're doing
pretty [ __ ] well yeah i mean if
there's one thing i can say you're a
personality sydney
you are definitely a personality
congrats on being a personality
you made it dude i felt so bad because i
remember like i don't know if you
remember this but
uh i i didn't knows you but i knew you
because of voice acting right do you
remember this yeah
i do i feel so bad about this but now i
don't give a [ __ ] yeah i know
i know you sound calm yeah so i knew
sidney from voice acting
and so when i met sydney when i first
saw her in person i was like
oh [ __ ] it's her
you're like hey and that was that was
like the reaction that sydney like was
so scared of because there'd be so many
times where we'd be walking around and
she'd just
see like a person like turn around and
she's like yeah and would be like
you know you know we need to leave we
need to leave right now oh god oh god oh
god
not the greatest sort of like oh i'm a
celebrity but more of like oh [ __ ] yes
i need the other pair of sunglasses
first met sydney and then i realized
that it was her and i asked her i was
like cydia are you
like cringe girl i think i said that and
you were like you said that
i'm like i'm never gonna talk to this
guy
she was like i have no idea what
compelled me to ask you i think
like as i was talking to you it just
came in my head and i was like say it
connor say it [ __ ] say it
i don't know why i would never do that
normally i'd normally go home and
[ __ ] analyze
enhance you know but yeah i asked you
and then i remember when you told the
story the first time about how hard it
was i was like oh [ __ ]
that's awkward jokes about it i'd be
like i don't know him well enough to
tell him to stop
because i don't mind now obviously but
back then i was like just like
because because it's weird for me
because i found out about the whole
leafy thing
after yeah yeah so like when i first met
you
all i knew you was god's partner yeah
yeah so it was really like
weird hearing that story like afterwards
because i don't know if you told me or
someone else told me
maybe i think maybe i think it was my
first probably when he first met
yeah hi i'm the chris
i think i got you drunk enough like by
the way i was in a leafy video
like something came up and like you were
like oh do you do stuff online i'm like
no but maybe you see me
at that time yeah and i don't know maybe
it's because i wasn't on youtube
as much at the time like i was on
youtube but i wasn't going
around watching other youtubers i'm like
cripplingly addicted to youtube yeah and
also like at that point as well i hadn't
been on 4chan in
years right so i didn't know what the
[ __ ] was happening over there as well so
then when i saw that video after you
told me about it i was like
oh okay this is the video that people
are talking about but i think
yeah but it was really weird like i
don't know if i'm maybe the first one
i think you actually were like you're
the first only person who's just like
didn't know okay if it's any
constellation i don't think it was that
bad thank you
yeah it was way worse i don't know i
don't think it was that bad either i
think
i thought it was pretty obvious to me
but i guess i think it's because it's
anime people like anime's cringe
yeah that's why especially back then as
well yeah yeah
like when you see videos of like because
sometimes i don't know why i love doing
this i just like search like 2008
conventions or 2010 conventions and just
watch vlogs
yeah from people with like 100 views you
get some of the like
best [ __ ] from doing that because
there's like so much in drama between
these friends
yeah of like like cody left on day two
because he refused to share the bed with
me and it's like it'll be like a hundred
hundred of you vlogging it'll be the
[ __ ] like [ __ ] in the bedroom
and i couldn't [ __ ] believe it it'll
be one
like i remember this one time and i cuz
when i i went i guessed at a convention
like indeed
in the uh some indiana convention not
any popcorn another one and this
convention been going on for a while so
i was going back every single year and
finding vlogs of it yeah
and then there was this one guy from
like 2010
and he opens up the vlog with yeah so
cody's not here
you guys know why and it doesn't explain
why
and for some reason that's so funny i
killed him
i straight up because because like two
like mid-2000s conventions
i remember it just seemed like you're
walking into another world
like the rules of like i remember when
just the rules of normal society did not
apply to anime conventions you know
i i tried so far i usually hate watching
like cringe compilation videos because
like i just i personally can't stand
yeah i don't find them funny
but the one types of cringe compilations
i [ __ ] love is like the mid-2000s
like
marriage proposals
oh [ __ ] best it's like it's like
watching like it's just it's
always outside of the convention center
and there's a crowd of people
all the same cosplayers always it's
usually like naruhina or somehow
somebody like it's always now here now i
don't know what it is i think one of my
favorite videos on youtube of all time
is this video called 2001 and anime
odyssey oh my god
i remember showing it to them at
christmas and it's just basically a
highlight reel of this very old
anime documentary that follows like so
good follows these people
at certain anime conventions like this
was before the mid-2000s it's like
like the late 90s yeah yeah yeah and oh
my god some of the stuff that was going
on there was what was what was the name
of the dude
johnny otaku johnny otaku my man
[Music]
[Applause]
i actually searched his uh searched up
his story after i saw that video
so do you explain johnny johnny otaku
is one of the most like cr like one of
like one of the creepiest kind of
self-confident anime fans you could like
you could like ever see one of the most
infamous anime fans the most
infamous the kind of guy who brings you
to a convention is like oh i know
everyone here yeah
i know he's like sure he's like not even
a guest but he's like i know the stuff
yeah yeah so i remember in the
documentary he was like running his own
radio show
um that was like an anime radio show and
he was trying to be a voice actor
um that he said he was saying he was no
no he was
he was he was an aspiring voice actor
yeah
which you know going off tangent if you
i don't know why people use the word
aspiring
essentially shivers down my spine like
when i go when i go on a twitter profile
and i see the word aspiring and i'm like
come on dude
you can do better yeah aspiring aspiring
voice actor just means i own a yeti
snowball
just saying just say just say you're a
voice actor or just don't put it in just
just like one or the other you know
but yeah he was an aspiring voice actor
and
i i searched up his story after i saw
the video and i saw like this
funimation panel where they they were
talking about this person
called like john or johnny or something
that that tried
so hard to get an audition that they
literally had to ban him
from the funimation officers because he
was like stalking employees and all this
[ __ ]
and then i kind of just connected the
dots i was like
wait a minute there's this guy called
johnny in this one
in this one video who's like really
aspires to be like vic manana
and then there's this another story by
funimation employees who's
talking about this guy called johnny
stalking funimation employees at their
offices
and i'm like oh that's yikes can i just
say
can we get johnny on target that would
be [ __ ] legit
johnny if you're watching this please
come to japan i know you love this
country just
just come here we'll put you on the
podcast yeah i want to hear the story
yeah
i i implore the viewers at home just
type in any anime convention and type in
like
what two thousand okay vlogs yeah that's
so funny watch 2001 and anime obviously
it's a 30 minute video
but my god it's it's it's so good it's
you'll have the time of your life oh my
god
but like going back to you sydney going
back to your your
the japan trip i would say that
completely ruined
your perception of like of of like anime
and weebs in general
so do you want to explain like why that
happened all right what happened were
you the stereotypical weeb
before everything's like describe
describe yourself describe what you were
like before and describe
what happened described of course like
because i okay the beginning was like i
had a japanese foreign exchange student
because i was like oh japanese people of
nihongo desu
and it's like kind of like joey dies
inside
but i i'm definitely up until i think i
met her i calm down a lot i'm like
she's pretty normie
and then um she let me stay at her house
in japan after she went back home after
a year
i was 17. okay um so i went to her house
and then i kind of just went everywhere
in tokyo that was like anything and the
whole time
like i loved the trip it was don't get
me wrong but it did do i think that it
was
anime you know heaven here like do i
think like
so what was your image of japan before
coming here for the first time come here
and i'd be like an instant like everyone
be like oh kawaii blonde girl
do you want to be an internet you want
to be an idol in japan just take over
the
country remind us she says she had no
self-confidence
once i like grow up and realize like man
[ __ ]
life really hits you like a truck and
then like once i grew up and like
[ __ ] how come i left japan and i wasn't
like prime minister
that's like every white guy when he goes
to new country
because like like i'm just like what if
i'm not so good
and then i then i made like i started
reflecting yeah definitely just on
everything and i'm like
[ __ ] anime lied to me this is a normal
country
and then just like because like you you
i remember you were telling me stories
about how you were like cosplayed in
akihabara and stuff like that um
because like when i went to japan it was
2012 and about i think a year prior or a
year and a half prior on ohana
finished and um we went to and i really
love anahana like um
but um so i went to the village for uh
which is where it was based off of and
um since i was like
the blonde blue eyed girl they're like
oh manma so they made me like dress up
as men
for a picture who made you dress up we
went to the place that was like
because they were having a festival on
ohana right and then
there was like a street completely
dedicated towards like looking like the
anime like they had a secret base and
everything and um
so we went to the store i think where
they were like beginning to run
everything and then people
were just like they're like oh [ __ ] like
we need somebody to like cosplay to gain
more people to like want to come over
and then uh so they just like they asked
me find a white girl
and then because i think she's meant to
be white in the anime
if i remember like they were but why is
her name i don't get into that
yeah i think she's supposed to be
japanese
but you know anime being enemies like
let's just make them not japanese yeah
so then they made me wear uh
men mccos like the white dress yeah yeah
and um
just i don't think i've ever felt so
wanted
like japanese people just like i just
remember like the flashing like i
couldn't see they're just like telling
me to pose and i was just like
[ __ ] i'm just like like i'm just blonde
hair blue-eyed and
where the madman dress and i've never
felt so loved
jesus you got too much love or you
didn't get anything
didn't you get accused of being racist
why not why not yeah let's just jump
right in so yeah so
i went so okay i when i was studying in
england i quickly had to pick a thing i
wanted to major in and
i just picked japanese all right i'll
say it i
i majored in that we've of course
and um so i was so i went to university
in london
and um oh god i really hope he doesn't
watch this um so okay
so i had a japanese professor and um we
obviously write essays as you do in
university yeah
and um he let us pick the genre like
what we want to write about exactly and
i picked about like kind of japan's
fascination with westerners
and like kind of their looks they kind
of like you know me like stuff like that
and so i i felt really good about it
like i thought it was the best i ever
wrote
garnet read it he's like i i actually
thought it was a good it was a good
essay
and then i when i was like so excited
i'm like this is the best and like i was
i'd never been so hyped for a grade
you know you did good [ __ ] i can't wait
to get that [ __ ] a
but then i get like my the grades back
two weeks later and it's a zero out of a
hundred
and i'm just like what the [ __ ] right
and so i messaged him like
why'd i get a zero for this he's like
because it was like he never explicitly
said
racist but he's like you are very
insensitive to japanese people and just
like
just a lot of stuff and i remember just
like crying because i'm like oh my god
it's like such like calling me racist
so it was your professor like full
jacket yeah he was full he literally
came like he was older japanese man who
came to like
teach japanese like culture in the
university and uh
yeah maybe he just maybe you just gave
him a pill he couldn't swallow it yeah
yeah yeah
like [ __ ] she called me out
[Music]
when you told me that i'm like but like
every single sign near your house is
like white people
yeah yeah that's what people have it's
like the gym
i i don't see a single asian person
yeah the longer i live here the more i'm
like man i shouldn't have got a [ __ ]
zero on
hundreds because i remember you go back
that great and you're like
i had to convince you for the week that
you just weren't racist
maybe i'm racist maybe i'm like you're
all like [ __ ] martin luther's just
like i'm just dropping these truth bombs
just can't handle it
legit i was like convinced i was racist
completely i was convinced
[ __ ] what if i have internal racism and
i never even knew
yeah no but yeah i
i he almost i almost failed university
because of that
wow he made me um rewrite it and he
actually gave me good points for i had
to write
about i had to read memoirs didn't you
drop out anyway i did
jokes on you i wanted that credit so
yeah you could argue that the professor
was being racist to you
[ __ ] wow that's a vsauce okay
reverse uno card
excuse me sir i believe you are the
racist one here
coming at me that's just 20 20 today
oh my god so i got to ask what was like
the anime community like when were you
in like your full weeb phase because you
you like
you like fully embraced it right like
how was anime conventions and everything
for you
yeah i wish i never went to anime
convention until like 2017. yeah my
first anime convention was like 20
20 like 2012 or something like that it's
still early yeah
yeah i hadn't even started youtube at
that point yeah wait so where was the
what year was the first anime convention
2009
nine yeah um it was anime milwaukee
anime milwaukee hit me up bro
no it's anime milwaukee and um i
remember because obviously i said i was
a full weep and everyone says like glob
i'm like oh my god that's so original
oh my god oh my god i got shivers down
my spine here
i just lost the game and i'm like that's
the most clever [ __ ] [ __ ]
wait what is gomping uh glomping is when
you
do you want to explain that you don't
know what glory is is that the
thing where you jump on they're just
like
it's like it's like you come up to a
random person and you literally just
like
yeah yeah and sometimes it's it's it's
like the most aggressive hug
you can it hurts it's it's like a rugby
tackle that's what it's like it's not
really always yeah
why is like so many things in anime
conventions just sound right like i
didn't
i didn't know you i didn't i didn't know
you could be assaulted by a hug until i
experienced the glomp
i'm just like oh that felt dirty what
the hell what the hell is that
shower do you what do you think of free
hugs
like i can't [ __ ] stand the free hugs
i'm like why would i want to hug a
sweaty stranger
but it's the last thing i ever want to
do i actually like before the whole
rhona thing happened like i remember
going to shibuya and almost every time
there's like a
freak there's a free hug sign i'm like
what who does this it's 2019 who does
this
if it's like a viewer who's like i want
a hug i'm like i got you but if it's
like just someone standing there who's
been hugged by like a hundred different
people that damn i don't want your hugs
yeah
your herpe ridden hugs get it off of me
but like yeah cause it's like you don't
know what they want from you like do you
want to feel my like
tender breasts on your sweaty showerless
body yeah exactly it's like it just
looks really rapey to me like
i'm i mean like the one meter radius and
i can smell the like like axe
i can feel it in my pores yeah no i
don't know i just even when i was
younger i just thought this [ __ ] was
stupid like
yeah i don't know if like yeah maybe
someone british i don't know we just
yeah
i think i don't know like stupid yeah i
mean i just like my personal space and
i remember like like go go go into anime
conventions back in the day just seemed
like
everyone looked for an excuse just to
violate your personal space as much as
possible
oh yeah and uh man remember like yowie
paddles
but i watched that i was like i'm so
glad i wasn't a convictions during that
time
yeah it just it just seemed like
something yeah what i heard about my
weight so people just
hit you no one had a problem with that
yeah that's just a physical assault yeah
extra steps
yeah physical assault with attitude
it's like if i just put the word like
like hentai on a belt and we're like
it's the hentai belt
son it's time i'm getting the hentai
belt out
father please i i saw the i what i heard
about the yowie paddle right i heard
stories about it's like this is gonna
this is gonna look amazing yeah this
thing
everyone's hitting it it must be amazing
if everyone's just letting it fly yeah i
see it and it's just like
burned in yowie like sans serif font
into a panel and i'm like this is what
everyone let each other hit them
there was like i've seen pictures of
like old conventions where there was
selling it
at like yeah they sold them yeah and i'm
like what is this [ __ ] hunger games
like it's just like
really available just like go to war
everybody
it just proves that they will literally
buy anything at an anime convention if
you just put the words yowie on it yeah
like
it's a [ __ ] wooden panel there is
literally nothing
special about this why are people buying
this material cost is like 10 cents
you're selling it for like five bucks
it's just it's there's so much [ __ ] now
to make a bedroom like who's buying this
like i you know the oh my god i mean i
know i feel i feel like it's just
it's just evolved now i think i'm
british now if you want to sell
something okay now i'm going to sell
something on an anime convention just
put a [ __ ] aha girl face on it
that [ __ ] will sell like hot cakes you
know i remember i would see people go
around with like these
these steins like the metal like steins
i'm like why is everyone holding a stein
and the [ __ ] is a stein like a really
big like
like german uh like mug and it was like
oh
and there was just someone like the app
and like the vendors it was just selling
like
like weird kind of concoctions and i was
like
this is why why are you carrying around
a metal ass jug all day that you can
refill
when you just drink some [ __ ] water
out of it like you ever have a water
bottle to hold a [ __ ] glass all day
yeah this thing was huge yeah and i'm
just like what is wrong with anime facts
don't buy
anything that's put in front of them
like yeah it's a deal though maybe maybe
if you look
closely at the stones
it's the yowie stein i just think
my my parents just [ __ ] they just
told me everything that you don't need
is a scam connor
like seven up you don't need that you
got water it's a scam
it's a scam that was pretty bomb they're
not gonna lie yeah
i prefer seven up over sprites yeah
thing as a kid and now i just think all
lemonade tastes
like mcdonald's mid what mcdonald's
sprites
sprite's the best what's the difference
between mcdonald's regular sprite
oh my god have you ever had mcdonald's
mcdonald's but it's just
actually why would i walk into a
mcdonald's when i used to
that that is true when i used to work at
mcdonald's because it's like a syrup
right it's like a
yeah so when we had to like connect it
one time i got like the
the coke syrup on my hands and i was
like
and it was like like the swedish it was
i imagine that's what
15 old me thought doing a line of coke
was like [ __ ] was so
sweet and juicy oh my god it was amazing
succulent
succulent it was amazing that was
beautiful and that was the only good
thing that ever happened working did you
guys
did you guys ever see the yowie guy at
like the first some of the first
conventions
okay so okay i don't know i there was
this guy
right i don't know how he got all around
the world but he'd go around some of the
biggest conventions
and you'd know it was the yowie guy
because there was there would be this
one booth
that would be something like yaoi and
the jinshi's and there would just be
this guy that would
just keep shouting out yeah we get your
yowie
i've met him you've met him i've met him
he was at a convention in finland
yeah i'm like i think i saw you in
america like
last month why are you here i saw him at
like an asen convention and then i saw
him again at like
mcm two months later i don't know how he
just like
and he he would always shout this out
and i remember
telling me that mr yowie's also missed a
world war
that's the worldwide i remember because
of how
aggressively he would [ __ ] sell yowie
to girls
like girls would come up and he goes yo
girl what you want what yaoi do you want
you
this girl is buying gay porn everyone
she is buying yowie hi what yaoi do you
want and then you
and then the guys would come up and
there would be a different guy selling
the jinshi's at the same booth yeah and
it would be like this indiscreet
drug dealer being like yo yo yo boy what
do you want like no one has to see
i'll [ __ ] bag it up no one has to see
it'll be coming to paperback penetration
stuff
yeah i don't know like i think he's got
gotten banned or something now because i
haven't seen him
that would annoy the [ __ ] out of me yeah
because like thinking back i'm like man
that probably wasn't cool for like any
girl who just
wanted to indiscreetly buy something
something oh it's like the next level
sexual assault
right it's like it's like it's like the
most like big brain sexual assault
it's like i'm not actually assaulting
you sexually but i kind of am by words
yeah yeah i love anime conventions but i
just feel like
i'm like out of my league man i'm like i
get there and i'm like i love
the atmosphere but sometimes you just
see weird [ __ ] and you're like all right
okay
i'm gonna head out i don't know what it
is when i hear about uh you go to ax or
something and hear about a group of guys
who have met on discord and
like and like rent out airbnb together
for some reason
ninety percent of the time that just
never ends up well oh i
did that and it went [ __ ] horrible i
hear that i'm just like that's that's
that's how murders happen well
the thing i thought was like right
listen this hotel is expensive yeah i
don't care who
is going to be in this room yeah i need
to just fill it and get this price down
yeah i'm broke as [ __ ] i need this hotel
to cost
100 dollars for this whole thing or i'm
out yeah yeah
you kind of like take the area of like
the hotel room and you're like
how many times can i divide this by a
human body so okay that's how many
bodies are sleeping in this room right
now you've got to become the host
no one can argue whether you get like
the best yeah it's like well i arranged
it what are you gonna do
it's in my name yeah you mean maybe take
the floor you wouldn't dare
this episode is sponsored by honey these
days it feels like online shopping is
the only shopping that we do that's true
that's true
i never go outside to shop anymore and
that's where honey comes in
it's the free browser extension that
scours the internet for promo codes and
automatically applies the best one
available at the checkout i am reading a
script
so gentlemen do you love spending money
i love spending money but you
can't talk to that guy do you know what
i love more than spending money tell me
getting free money oh my god i love free
money
gentlemen here's how it works you get
honey on your computer for
free in two easy clicks by going to
joinhoney.com
trash taste then when you're checking
out on one of its over 30
000 supported sites
well honey pops up and all you have to
do is click apply coupons
that's it you save money and you just
wait a few seconds and you'll apply all
the coupons automatically
you do zero effort and for nothing
for free you gain free money or you save
free money
i love free money who doesn't love free
money i love pizza
[Laughter]
just just keep that i also love pizza
and honey saved me
personally tons of money on pizza and i
know as you guys know
pizza is pretty [ __ ] it's commented
i'll complete your sentence pizza and ex
pizza is expensive and i saved a lot of
money off of
how much money did you save cherry i'd
say at least 10 20 bucks
at least minimum yeah i use honey on a
lot of clothing store and recently i do
i did save about like 30 bucks on them
oh sure i never put honey on pizza but i
definitely use honey
for pizza the sponsor for today's video
joking aside i've actually used it it's
good by the way i've saved like 10 bucks
and stuff before just saying
and that's honey it's simple it's free
it's easy to use
what are you waiting for go install it
today honey has found it's over 17
million members over two billion dollars
in savings that's about the same amount
as god spent on gacha
wow you just miss the beast please
please sponsor me i need i need help
from my gotcha not only that but honey
supports all kinds of retailers from
tech and gaming sites to fashion brands
to even food delivery yes
including pizza oh my god jointhoney.com
trash taste links in the description
below that's joinhoney.com
trash taste thank you to honey sponsor
of today's episode back to the video
do you guys though have like at least
that one like
anime convention story that you share
with people though because like i have
like a million
yeah i mean like with that one that just
sticks out to you it's just like you
meet somebody or i should i guess
specify
that one convention story where somebody
was the biggest [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah because i we have one
morals just go out the window i swear
i should we should probably tell this
one when we're both on this podcast um
because i remember the one the one guy
that ever stood out to
both of us i've told this story on
sydney's channel before
but it was the very first time me and
sydney had met
in person yeah and like probably started
dating so anyone who's been in
a long distance relationship will know
how
difficult that is like when you don't
get to see
your partner very often so you have to
like treasure every moment that you get
to
you know be with your partner yeah now
this was the very first time we me and
cindy had met
in person and it was 2014 a cent
and on the last day um we had to say our
goodbyes
yeah and obviously it was a very very
a very very i know this one it was a
very very tearful goodbye because
obviously
at the time we didn't know when we would
next get to see each other right
so sydney was in my arms and she was
like crying it was like
it wasn't like a subtle cry it was a
proper crying it was like an ugly crap
it was like makeup spewed all over your
face kind of crying
like he's going to war yeah yeah
and like i'm like comforting her i'm
just just as as we're just
as we're just like hugging together i
just hear in the corner of my ear
giggot and i was just like and i was
just like
no way i know she's like it's not even
the worst part yet
i love this story so much and i just saw
her just be like
hi and and there's just just this guy
standing at me and he had like he had
like the
you know the surprise face and you know
i i was i was trying to like
like signal like look look at sydney
look at sydney
look at sydney like like just just give
us a moment because this is my very
first convention
in america and like probably my very
first convention as like as like a
youtuber so i wasn't used to getting
recognized if i had
if this happened now i'd be like dude
can you give us a moment but back then
i did not know how to deal with it you
didn't know how to say hold on yeah i
didn't have to say no basically
so he was like can i take a picture and
i'm just like
inside i was like is this guy serious
yeah it's right this guy [ __ ] serious
right now
i'm just like i'm like um oh okay sure
so like we separate right yeah we
stepped forward to the side and he goes
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
i i got this i got this i got this i got
this so
so he he tries taking some pictures
right and he does he does the thing
where the first selfie he's not happy
with so he's just like no
let me try again okay okay now you get
three and then i'm like yeah and he
tries the third time
and he's still not happy and then he
looks over to sydney
makeup all over her face tears down her
tears down her [ __ ] face or like all
over her cheeks
and i'm just like don't do it don't
[ __ ] do it
don't [ __ ] do it can you take a
picture from me
i'm crying and i'm like sure because i
didn't know i was so
i did it oh
he has the goal to ask cindy to take a
picture for us
and like i i was just i went from like
really really sad that i'm not gonna say
sydney for a while to just like confused
angry
to be like is this guy for real is this
he's
is he for real like how how are you
feeling in that moment
i was pretty pissed i was like angry but
i was like because i thought maybe like
is this normal
yes he's like a big star i should know
so he
should know better and at least at least
he wasn't like
hey sydney do you want to be in the
photo with us oh my god
that would have been about clean
yourself up and then
that was the worst time someone asked me
for a photo i was queuing up to take a
[ __ ] at ax
i kid you not right i'm taking a [ __ ]
and the guy
so you've got to like line up because
the [ __ ] toilets are tiny in the uh
ax convention yeah yeah
and uh the guy's having a piss on the
the cubicle
another keep it called uh urinal and uh
i'm just on my phone he turns around
it's like
c-dog yo what's up thinking that like
that's it because we're a [ __ ] toilet
yeah yeah
can i take a photo i'm like you didn't
even wash your hand
near me like still zipping up his pants
no
we can't take a picture right now i'm
talking about to take a [ __ ]
in the toilet with other people pissing
at the same time it's filled and i
i feel like i'm the [ __ ] yeah yeah
because now everyone's looking at us and
i'm like
are you kidding me dude i'm not i've had
it i've had a similar thing but i was
actually at the urinal
yeah yeah
i've been there and the dude directly
next to me was like yo joey what's up
and i'm like can you not see that penis
in my head yeah my stream would instant
stop at that moment
i think mine actually got faster because
i'm like i'm pretty sure this guy's
about to ask a photo no
i'm not about to get a photo taken my
hand
because like i didn't have to react to
that because i remember
this the exact thing came the exact same
thing happened to me when i was in the
urinal
and it's the case where there are like
five urinals in a row yeah and i was
in like one of the one at the end yeah
and i knew something was wrong
when a guy chooses the one right next to
me and i'm just like
here we go here we go
and i'm like and i'm like what why are
you like my first instinct is like why
are you standing in the urinal next to
me there are
you know if if you're not a guy there's
an unwritten
etiquette to to like toilets where if if
the urinal
next to you is like free and there's
like more urinals other than one excuse
free
basic instinct you don't go to the one
next to the person always already
pissing you you don't want to be that
creepy that's
basic basic urinal etiquette yeah you
don't want to be that creep who's like i
don't want to look at his penis
but i want to look at him look at his
penis
yeah so um i i finished my um
i finished my business and for some
reason he asked for a handshake i'm like
can you at least let me wash my hands
first man i won't touch the [ __ ]
pretty sure that's how corona
so what was your like most like weird or
just strange convention experience
before you're a youtuber like
or before you met khan like any any
weird say for example
like the first convention um i would say
like actually it was probably
i was doing like say voice acting online
you know i wasn't like massive at that
point
like i was a senior in high school and i
actually worked at the maid cafe at
ant-man milwaukee
of course you did of course of course
yeah yeah yeah yeah i couldn't you
didn't even need to tell me i just
assumed
oh yeah god i really hope this guy
doesn't watch us but um so i was just
kind of like we had 10 minutes off right
so i was gonna go get some water or
something and this guy is just like
wow uh are you working at the maid cafe
and i thought like had my maid
of john we all had the same
yeah and he's like okay and i'm like
okay and i was on the escalator and then
he turned away and like and then i
turned away
and then when we were closing up for the
night this guy comes up and he hands me
like this dollar that he origami into a
shirt
and um he's like do you think this is a
really cool like thing and i'm like
he's like you can keep that you can keep
that dollar i'm like
you're frothing at this finally
roughing up the loins i was like oh [ __ ]
he gave me a dollar
and then um so i was just sitting down
waiting for like to get my parents
started like waiting for the night to
end
and then he just sat down and then he
just didn't say anything
and then like like 20 minutes goes by
and i'm like i'm gonna go in the back
and i stayed there for two hours and
he's still there waiting
and so i actually had the manager go out
and yell at him to get out and i feel
bad because he's actually really shocked
like he thought i was genuinely could
come out be like when's our date
and um i mean i guess that's not like
the most creepiest thing like
that that doesn't sound like sounds kind
of rapey to me yeah that's a telerate
but it was definitely something i look
back and i'm like i kind of feel bad but
another way
he probably could have would have been
better about it i swear like i don't
know what it is about anime conventions
that just
turns anime fans into just monkeys like
i don't know i think it's just a lack
like a lot of young people
and a lot of old people who lack social
skills
yeah you know not to be mean but i think
a lot of people who go to it
there's a good chunk of people who go to
make conventions who don't really like
you know who
socially yeah they don't really
socialize too much outside of
you know maybe playing games online and
yeah i don't know i feel like
i think there's a lot of who just
assumed that because you liked the same
thing as me
yeah i'm definitely glad that i don't
know that i when i was younger i didn't
interact with people because i feel like
i would have been weird i'm i'm like i'm
i'm kind of glad i didn't go to anime
conventions that early as well because
like seeing how many stuff is coming out
about the smash community and stuff
i can only imagine what's happening oh
there's like animals
i can easily get based on what i've seen
in private like people do
and i make conventions now i can only
imagine how i'm honestly surprised the
smash convention was called out
before the anime convention scene yeah
yeah i'm sure there's
horrible stories they go behind the
scenes i think i think the problem is
with anime conventions a lot of the time
it's like
not like the celebrities like the
organizers sometimes yeah and
i mean there are stories obviously yeah
and it's kind of hard to it's kind of
hard to
it sucks but like cancel someone who no
one cares about yeah yeah i mean like
yeah
when you cancel like a community like
smash you've got like these big names
right and yeah you when you
bring it out it's like a i care about
that person yeah that's like dude the
event organizer of x-con
in your area is a rapist like who oh
who's that like yeah there's a console
on them
at least yeah it's bad i mean i'm not
trying to make light of any of that i
mean
it's it's pretty [ __ ] up but i mean
that's kind of how it is right it's
unfortunate
um i don't know it's a depressing topic
obviously that people don't like talking
about it's not that funny
let's change the subject but um okay but
like i want to know right
having how how you've done youtube for
how long would you say now
like the beginning of youtube since the
beginning but okay
as a as a job full-time job as a
full-time youtuber how are you doing
yeah you're in a little over a year and
a half year and a half
two years okay so like i i cause i
always ask people who like kind of come
into the whole full-time youtube thing
like
as of recently right because like being
a full-time youtuber
now is completely different to like
being a full-time youtuber
god so like as someone who's been there
from the beginning of youtube
how would you say it's like changed as a
full-time thing
as as opposed to like just doing it as a
hobby i think definitely like it's more
profitable now obviously back then in
the beginning i mean it's not like i'm
not saying like you're rolling in it by
any means like your guts like like
none of my videos are monetized
i can't really complain about that tell
me the video where you reviewed the
[ __ ] of the round table wasn't
monetized are you saying this episode
are you saying oh sponsor yes if if not
for patreon and sponsors you just
wouldn't have a job
but you're getting out there though and
that's like that's the important thing
yeah and then if you get like if people
watch you then people are gonna be like
[ __ ] let's get this [ __ ] to advertise
our [ __ ] [ __ ] right and then that's
i mean definitely it's like back in the
monetary days when youtube wasn't so
pissy because it was bound to happen
yeah it was about of course like
everything
is going to happen really somebody like
me shouldn't be monetized
but i i wonder because like back then i
almost think for me like
youtube was as much of like a social
thing for me as much as like i enjoyed
making the videos it was more about like
what a because it was the same with
voice acting for me well the the major
reason i
i kept doing voice acting i liked it so
much is that it was like how i
socialized with those people yeah yeah
and i almost felt like youtube was an
extension of that where
half the time which is why you know when
we said in the ages ago where i was like
they're only making videos for each
other et cetera et cetera because
i remember when i did it like when you
first start you kind of do
make videos in a sense for your peers
and for like to
impress one another because it's a very
social thing when you're smaller because
there's no pressure yeah right it's like
i just want to make videos my mate made
a really cool video i want to make a
cool video to like
you're just digging around with your
friends right right and half the funny
like
what i thought was funny at the time
probably not funny at all yeah stuff i
made was because i'm like dude my
friends are going to [ __ ]
love this yeah they left their ass off
right that's why i made it half the time
and i feel like that's that aspect
pretty much goes
instantly when you start doing it full
time yeah you still do make friends
obviously you know we're all youtubers
and friends but
the aspect of making videos for like a
social purpose
completely goes yeah i find yeah yeah i
mean i i'd still
say i do kind of make videos for social
purposes because
it's it's still like technically because
you're talking about current topics a
lot yeah i mean
and there's also like i i when we talk
about youtube
i see youtube now as like i just make
youtube for
like a general audience not just like an
anime watching audience so
like there are a lot of other youtubers
out there who have to do things that are
like
have nothing to do with anime but i
still respect their content
and like it's the best [ __ ] feeling
when there's you meet a guy
or a guy or a girl who has nothing to do
with your community
and you find out that watch your content
and you're like i love your stuff yeah
i'm like wait a minute i love your stuff
too
everybody class did we just become best
friends
that's your best moment cause you're
like yeah we're gonna hang out right
yeah oh yeah we are yeah
we're gonna hang out we're not gonna
make a video we're just gonna hang out
just gonna chill yeah yeah
you know you know you found a good like
new youtuber friend when you meet for
the first time and
the word collab just isn't said for like
five more times
the best yeah like like you don't even
take a selfie together yeah yeah yeah
yeah
like you just enjoy each other's like
essence the worst i [ __ ] the biggest
thing i hate is when uh
someone is like hey let's collab and i'm
like all right what do you have in mind
i don't know just want to collab
and i'm like can you come with like an
idea or something
like i don't want to do the work if it's
your collab yeah
like i i can't stand it like just collab
let's just do it like
what what do you want to do because tell
me what you want it's so easy to don't
collab
i can't think of my own videos what
makes you think i'm going to help you
with
yeah exactly sorry i'm angry i just had
so many moments where that happened you
came in with a bit of a chip on your
shoulder
i guess i do so like how long do you
think like currently because like i
assume you want to like continue to like
evolve your content in some
ways right definitely i i definitely
don't as much as it probably pains
some people to hear i don't want to just
stick with hentai i want because you
know i i'm i have other things i like to
do i'm not some
nympho maniac as many people have
alluded to
yeah well what are people's like
assumption on you based on your content
a lot of people have actually asked me
it's like do you just like have sex all
the time do you just read sex is that
all you [ __ ] do and i was like why
would you think that
there are people who do what what would
you
do
whatever would make you think in the
morning okay it's like
to you is it like it's hentai now has
your relationship with like hentai
changed because we were talking last
week about how our relationship with
anime has changed because
even though we still very much enjoy it
it is part of the job as well
yeah if anything i would say like my
knowledge and just like appreciation of
it has grown deeper
and just like kind of like it's more
like i i
never really changed too deeply i would
say like in terms of like
enjoying it as sort of a hobby now it's
just kind of like just reading it not
even just for like
to get horny or just like enjoy it the
last thing i want
is like i'm mid wank and i'm thinking
this is going to make a great video
like that's the thing right like do you
ever get to the point where you're just
reading a doji
in the back of your mind you're like i
could just read this
or i need to be reading this because
that actually kind of that does suck
because it's like sometimes you're just
like okay
all right i'm i might i don't want to
ruin porn
yeah not that i'm fond of it anyway i
just don't want to form an attachment
this is why i find it so hard to stream
sometimes because i i like i
video games like my my one last bastion
of like a hobby that i can just turn to
whenever like maybe i'm like burnt out
anime like i i get that i do i i think
it's like 50 50 for me on the video game
like there's some video games like
league of legends is just stressful to
stream
because like i'm inting i'm owen 8 on
stream i'm laughing it off and every
single time i die you look at my eyes
and i'm like
but like you know playing like [ __ ]
super mario on stream he's chill as [ __ ]
because
yeah game game for me is half off as
well because like i don't
stream every game i play i'm saying yeah
so like some games i'm just like
like i could have easily [ __ ]
streamed animal crossing for like
five months straight and being like yeah
that's content yeah but that game is so
personal to me that i'm like i don't
want to stream it like i i
that just that's just something that i
just want to keep completely separate
from any monetary not any corpse party
right
yeah right like 100 like if it's like
cold spotty i'll be like [ __ ] you i'll
stream that [ __ ] because it's [ __ ]
corpsepod
like i'm not gonna play cold spotty on
my own
why the [ __ ] would i do that i'd argue
there's some like even though
gaming for me is still like i try to
make it my personal thing there are some
games that i
genuinely think are better enjoyed with
an audience oh yeah you agree like yeah
absolutely
like you know i'm just trying to think
of someone at the top of my head like
mario 64 like when i stream
oh my god that [ __ ] was [ __ ] fun yeah
yeah like because people are just giving
me [ __ ] for being like
crap at the game and i'm like you want
to try and play this game after like a
15-year game
stuff like like mario party is really
fun being streamed mario kart's really
fun mario kart's fun streaming yeah
uh like i think any game that has a very
easy to understand concept with an
immediate like
feedback loop is like great the games
where you have to queue up five minutes
play for 40 minutes multiplayer games
don't work
i don't think i don't like watching
other people play league on stream
really
except for like the lcs yeah um and all
the worlds yeah worlds
because you started streaming recently
right sydney oh actually
before i started doing youtube i tried
being a twitch streamer full time
no way really what for all like good
like
what did you stream uh out stream mostly
resident
evil really i really like like shooting
games because
it's like
that was that was back when we were
living in thailand and sydney like
because of her visa status she couldn't
get like a proper job there
so she would like try to take any like
odd jobs or like contractual jobs that
she could and like on the side i was
like
well you don't want to be a youtuber
because she was still kind of scarred
from the leafy thing so i was like yeah
why not try streaming you know that's
uh how did that go for you it actually
went okay like i got five viewers
and um actually my mods now that are
like man my discord as well as like
everything
are actually the people the five people
from that time oh really yeah and um
that's how you know they're real ones
like i want to grow my audience and then
guns like just try doing youtube i'm
like
[ __ ] all right i'll do it and then just
did you too instead
so do you plan to like go back into
streaming streaming's actually a lot of
work isn't it like it's oh yeah
i was gonna ask about that what do you
think about the whole streaming versus
youtube debate
because they always [ __ ] argue it's
like all streamers don't put any effort
in and the vice president
vice versa if your streaming is hard
like streaming you like talk to people
constantly you'd like
be entertaining non-stop for hours and
hours like constantly like
it feels like you're being like you have
to be excited peppered energetic
otherwise you're boring
yeah it's like if you had to pick like
if you say you were you could be just
successful in either career choice being
a youtuber or a streamer
putting in the same amount of hours
which one would you prefer to be 100
100 youtubers i think i i do youtubers
yeah because
streaming is i think every day it's
constant yeah i i
i think i find streaming easy like i i
can just chat [ __ ] for like five hours
no problem yeah well you're like one of
the most
extroverted introverts i've met like
like
there are times when i'm just like i
just don't want to talk
especially when especially when i'm
streaming my stream limit is two hours
after two hours i'm just like
man i hate talking moving my mouth is
just effort now i still love doing 24
hour streams i've done like five i think
in total
that sounds like torture that sounds
like torture the last
eight or six hours are just pure pain
and the last two are like you're a
zombie
yeah like you forget i would be like oh
i haven't spoke for a minute i'm sorry
chat
that's what it feels like though but but
it's it's good because it gets people
excited because they know that they can
just turn it on but like
i don't know i i i find streaming the
i easy when i do it but the problem is
is that i don't know how i could do it
five days a week
i like that with youtube okay i can work
14 hours a day for a week if i want to
but i can also just not work for a week
if i
if i've prepared properly yeah right and
i really love that flexibility
and i feel like with streaming even i
even i've started getting it a little
bit i'm like wait why did i lose 200
subs
yeah i haven't streamed in a week yeah
and then it's like oh oh [ __ ] am i
getting that pressure of a stream away
it's like
yeah i've got to keep myself you got to
maintain yourself right and it's
like it's almost like you're gamifying
it but it forces like
you see these streamers do like 12-hour
day the 12-hour streams a day
like four or five times a week and i'm
like that can't be healthy yeah they're
just they're just built for that kind of
stuff right like it's it's they're just
built different
yeah they're just built different man
what can i say honestly like
i i really do think that streaming like
i i think i'm gonna i'm gonna say this
and i'm gonna probably piss people off i
think i think streaming takes way less
talent i think it just takes
a lot of patience i think it takes a lot
of learning and effort like i think
anyone can be a streamer i think for
some things on youtube it's a lot harder
to succeed
um yeah i think youtube has become very
specialized i don't know i i feel
like um i feel like it's like
half and half because i feel that with
streamers
to stand out in this day and age you
have to be you have to have something
about you that makes you stand out
that's true
like you have to be a youtuber like yeah
all you have to be a youtuber and it's
even then it's just a matter of time for
vichy was get so over saturday yeah
that's that it's gonna it's gonna be
already happening yeah yeah exactly
right
i mean that's why hotter life have like
a um have a
audition period yeah like there's
there's it's no coincidence that
everyone in hot life is really really
good at being entertaining it's because
they [ __ ] audition for it i mean i'm
not saying that like
you know it it requires no talent
whatsoever i just think the
the barrier of entry to i mean even
twitch is really hard to get an
audience on yeah i feel like youtube
it's easy to get to the first thousand
subs
whereas on twitch it's hard to go from
zero to ten like that's
hard i just feel like with youtube
there's more opportunity
for creators because with streaming you
are way more limited in your ideas of
what you can
do and not saying you can't do like
original ideas but you are way more
limited than what you can put in a
youtube video
per se that's true that's true but i
don't know i feel like youtube has
become
so competitive recently to be even
notable whatsoever you do i'd argue
twitch is like
even more competitive really you think
so yeah i think twitch is way more
really okay okay
enough i i would have no idea how i
would go about throwing myself on twitch
if i wasn't already established yeah
yeah well
i wouldn't either yeah whereas on
youtube i'd be like maybe i can do
like an interesting video idea or like
right you know like tackle a certain
topic in the way in a way that no one
else has because let's be real when it
comes to twitch
like discovery oh it's garbage it's it's
[ __ ] like people
don't go on twitch to watch vods yeah
like that that's just not how it likes
as in like to be a successful twitch
streamer is it the problem of i'm not
entertaining enough or the algorithm is
[ __ ] me
like it's a bit of both i reckon because
like again
it stems down to that whole thing of
like you know if you have more than 20
viewers
in a stream every stream then you're
technically in the top 10 of twitch yeah
right it's like it's there's just
anybody can do it but to maintain that
level of quality
throughout the entire time i think does
take somewhat of a talent all right
there's a lot of streamers like between
20 and 100 that just like
you build up that that like audience of
just pure like
commitment yeah just like constantly
interacting with them yeah yeah
and i think to get to that point is like
just requires just
not being a dick and dedication because
like i'll tell you one of the big
reasons why i was able to get into like
the youtuber scene versus like the
live streaming scene before like youtube
came along it's because
what i couldn't get into about like
streamers is that there's they're
basically always streaming
right they could be like they could be
they're streaming eight hours a day so
you
you can tune in anytime you you want but
you don't know what they'll be doing
you know sometimes i'll be playing a
certain game then you know i get that
you can just leave them
on them on in the background but i like
having like a piece of content that i
know
i can watch so we're vtubers most of
their streams are like one hour or two
hours long
so it's just like very segmented so i
know like
i know what i'm getting out of avicii
with stream you know they're going to be
playing for this set amounts
and you know it's on a schedule they're
going to be doing x
x show or playing x game and i can be
like okay
i'm going to watch this fiji for this
time and then i could you know
do something else whereas with twitch
it's just like do i want to put them on
in the background you know maybe maybe
not you know there's
there's nothing that inherently draws me
to their content
aside from if i really like that person
and also it's just so much easier to
like
watch back on vods on youtube because
youtube is built
as a already pre-recorded video service
right so like
yeah so it's just way easier to like go
back like if you missed a v tuber stream
then it's so easy to just go into the
channel and just see all the vods there
like a regular youtube channel yeah
right right whereas with twitch
looking through vods is a [ __ ] pain
in the ass because they've set it up so
shittily that's that's why everyone has
to [ __ ] highlight this channel
right exactly which yeah i want to get
as well
yeah i saw someone someone started
highlighting your your twitch streams as
well
yeah yeah they did they did and i want
to basically just
get one where i can just like you know
split the ad rep with someone so it's
like alright they just do it they get
the address
yeah and then it's just you know make me
yeah make content
more because like i mean if i'm
streaming i may as well turn it into
content right like
yeah if and if i have nothing to do with
it great like i can just you know
yeah i mean it's whatever i mean i i
yeah i i do think that twitch is [ __ ]
hard to get the ball rolling yeah that's
brutal
i mean i i would say that it's a skill
set that i don't have to be successful
on twitch like i
i i understand how the twitch audience
works and what the kind of content they
want
but that's the kind of grind that i like
yeah i cannot do that
yeah yeah like you're very like chill
yeah yeah
like my my my my social skills come in
burst i say and so
so does my inspiration right like i
don't know what it is i don't know if
it's the same with you guys but
either i'm working on like five to ten
different projects at once
or i'm like struggling to think of one
idea yeah exactly
it's like either i'm like man i've got
so many [ __ ] good ideas and i know
that when i'm done with these ideas i'm
like [ __ ] what do i do next i'm screwed
yeah which is why i would almost like i
almost like twitch because it's like
i never have to worry about thinking of
an idea i just turn it on and chat [ __ ]
and play games right whereas
with youtube it's like [ __ ] i gotta keep
one upping myself i'm gonna go stale
it's like how can you go stale if you're
just playing games right yeah yeah i
mean there probably is examples of it
but you know
so like how long do you for example like
think you could like
keep doing youtube or like how how long
like because because i
because you know i think everything you
ride or you yeah is that like because i
think every youtuber gets asked the
question like oh where do you sue
yourself in five years ten years like
that kind of stuff right which i think
is the stupidest question ever i guess
it's hard to kind of i guess what feels
right you know just go with the win like
because i definitely don't feel like
doing i'm i'm trying to like i have
plans to make my channel
not just hentai focused anymore i want
to show off some of my other talents
you know voice work maybe if i'm
talented
but um or just like other things that
i'm like that are interesting in the
anime spear
uh i don't cause you've done like a few
videos where you like go to you know
bars that have easier yeah that are
featured in manga yeah
and honestly i really like i honestly
really love those videos i
i guess just seeing just me out and
about you know do you feel like you got
drawn into just making content about
hentai just
because of you saw how well it was doing
did you feel pressure about it
of course of course i feel pressure
about it believe it or not
do i always want to make content just
about hentai of course not i
it just gets the collection it just gets
the like
of course i enjoy it and i wouldn't be
making anything i think is just
for the views for money because like
yeah
here's like a little trade secret that
i'm just gonna spill right now
like some of sydney's videos uh some of
cindy's videos ideas
have been ideas that i've pitched to her
because sometimes
i get ideas sometimes i get ideas and
i'm like
i can't do this for my channel but like
i live vicariously through sydney to be
like
yo sydney i can't i can't do this idea
for my channel can you like can you like
do it
can you yeah because i remember the the
one
like the one that jinshi i wanted to
like uh get someone to talk about was uh
retake
which going back to the fan fiction
thing i was talking about earlier
like this this is the this is the
dojinshi that got me
into thinking hey maybe fan fictions
aren't that bad
because this is retake retake to explain
to you
is basically just a entire [ __ ]
retelling
of the end of evangelion because i
remember i first when i first watched
the end of evangelion as a kid
um and i'm talking about the movie as
well yeah it is not
a satisfying conclusion if you don't
understand what's happening
and especially like i i have a deeper
appreciation of end of ava now
as an adult but as a kid i'm just like i
just want to i just want to see what
happens
and then through that i discovered
retake
and retake is retake is one of the most
satisfying fan fictions i have ever read
where it kind of ties up
every loose end that i wanted to be tied
up
in when i was watching the original ava
and it gave me the same kind of
conclusion and satisfaction within
myself that i would have felt
even if it was just a cannon like in my
head it is kind of just canon
i watched your video about it yeah
that's the reason why i know it exists
yeah yeah
because like and then i got her to read
it
yeah like we actually had to watch
evangelion first because i never really
watched evangelion probably till
recently
and then he showed me retake and we
shared the exact same opinions on it
like so you know that's true
we came at the exact same
oh my god you skipped the blow jobs too
same
and i'm like yo yo sydney why don't you
make a video about this
oh my god sydney why don't you make a
video though
and so you did that's what i did
i might be honest i'm like his little
entertainer and he's my agent but we
have like a little like sexy
relationship
pouring on the way you didn't you really
didn't have to
you're really going to do me like this
sydney
all right all i ask is what are you
doing
i don't know why i went in that
direction i'm listening
how does
yeah is there anything else you want to
mention or anything else you want to
talk about
what the that's a anything you want me
to pretend to like ask you about
what you want to tell just ask like what
jobs did i have previously what jobs did
you appreciate i'm curious
mcdonald's cool thank you
i don't know if you're actually asking
okay yeah we're actually okay
well when i was in high school my first
job was at a frozen yogurt place
and then i started i moved to england
and that's the widest thing you've ever
said
is that you're gonna elaborate more on
the frozen
did anything happen how long were you
there for uh four or five months
and then off the internet and then i
graduated high school and then i started
working at a bakery at a
supermarket no way i know before i
graduated high school supermarket bakery
and then i moved to england
and i started working at weatherspoons
worst job i've ever had
i hated it it's if you guys don't know
what weatherspoons is it's this cheap i
think you guys might have
yeah we mentioned it um the old people
there would start at like
8 a.m they always come in with like the
first thing they'd always order is shots
of like whiskey or vodka and they just
keep going all old british people are
like i don't know what's wrong man
they always go to the pub at like 9 a.m
to meet up with their other old friends
and they just get drunk that's all they
do
and they were mean they were mean they'd
always be like like they'd be like you
shouldn't be in our country
you're not like they were pretty mean
yeah i'd be screamed at every day and
it's like sometimes i'd cry and they'd
be like oh now you're just trying to
make me feel bad and i'm just like you
just told me to like you just call me a
[ __ ]
i just gave you yes you should feel bad
yeah
and like sometimes i pour a beer or like
not because i didn't really like know
how to pour beer
pouring a pint is a very strict
procedure yeah and they're just like you
dumb [ __ ]
like they would an old british man
would call you a dumb [ __ ] no way i
refuse to
call me a [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
and then just like sometimes i actually
when we moved to uh thailand i did
that that was when you kind of tried to
dip your job uh
dip your foot into like a lot of things
yeah i tried like a lot do you want to
talk about
that time where you were a english
teacher
you're an english teacher i was i was an
english teacher in thailand
um so uh garen's family
had like a friend and i would like it
was allowed um
in the country for like me to like kind
of help with
like because yeah it was it's all right
i wasn't being illegal you know
stealing thai people's money but um
i was an english teacher for uh children
from the ages of
one to uh four right so you're basically
a daycare
that basically sounds like dates yeah
yeah like i i just like kind of did that
is a bit exhausting
um but i remember the very first english
teaching job
she had so to to preface sydney loves
dogs
like oh my god like whenever she sees a
dog like you can hear it in a voice
because like her
her pop the pitch in her voice she
reaches a frequency that only dogs can
hear
you know it's like it's like a dog
whistle
yeah exactly it's it's like she she like
her voice goes into like dog whistle
territory
i remember the first day on the on the
job she uh
she was like dreading it and i remember
i had to drive her to this house
where she had to chew to these kids
private tutor yeah um for
like kids that were like age seven and
eight yeah
and i was like i don't want to go to
like this stranger's house but if they
like rape and kill me and i was like oh
but it's also 8 a.m and i don't want to
go
yeah so she was like complaining the
entire way there to be like maybe i
should quit now i'm just gonna quit like
like
i'm gonna go there i'm gonna look the
person in the eye and i'm gonna be like
you know what this job's not for me
so we pull up to this house and it's
like it's like a gated house with like a
patio on it
and there are just these they're just
these puppies puppies they were just
born that was just these puppies just
sitting in this patio the moment sydney
looked at them
all of the windows in the neighborhood
shattered
and she was like those are puppies right
there
and then a woman come a woman comes out
and was like
oh are you are you the teacher no that
was the house and she was like yeah i'm
like
give me those puppies give me the baby
you're just teaching english while
you're holding like full puppy
that's your english and i'd never seen
sydney like just get out the car as fast
as i had as
she had just realized this was the house
that she was about to teach him
and then obviously i hated english
teaching probably not the best at it
like
i was saying i was like didn't think
your english was that good to begin
what the [ __ ] that mean
because i say words like baby bit or
small
or like eye penetration
repeat after me because like okay like
going back to your like your weave phase
one thing i am kind of jealous of now
now that like living in japan
is that you you have like no fear when
it comes to
attempting japanese or like trying
japanese and everything like that be
like oh
chin chin
you hear me not that but like you you
have like no fear when it comes to like
attempting your japanese and
there are there have been times when
like in before we moved to japan because
i remember you were telling me the story
about when i had my signing at
bookwalker ax
and you actually met one of the uh
authors there
uh i i i don't think there was the don
machi
though i think i was was it the one
uh it was like the second time i met you
as was my older brother
it might have been monsters might have
been muslim somebody yeah it might have
been a violation
i didn't honestly i think i know you
introduced i was like a bit drunk
because we're day drinking do you want
to explain the story
um so i was at an anime con with my
uh onishan my brother at um you could
have just said bubba
i'm out
um like all of us like we went with a
group like we've got
our friends some of our friends from
england and my brother wanted to come
because he likes going to anime cons as
well
um and i'm really close with my brother
so he came with us to ax and we were
like day drinking a bit you know as you
can see
as you do it because you do especially
ax and then um
you got it to get through those lines
yeah oh my god oh my god yeah i got all
the story off this one yeah okay
here we go and um guard had a signing at
bookwalker not long after
and i was like about four or five beers
deep and that might as well be lethal
it was like 4pm okay but um and so
i i went in the back behind the book
walker signing thing
and um i was having my signing yeah but
someone else just finished their signing
and i was with my brother and i was i
was a bit drunk you know i'm not gonna
lie
and um so myelin obviously
which you guys obviously remember from
previous episodes was there and she's
like oh do you want to meet this guy's
name who i don't even remember
and i'm just like sure but i was pretty
obviously drunk
and i shook his hand and
i started speaking my shitty japanese i
was just like oh
konichiwa watashi no onichan
just like so there's like
and this guy's like all right and then
later did i find out that was the
author of monster music
i also have another story i go ahead
guys i just want to say this is actually
the coolest
one and i need to okay so we were at the
funimation party
and uh at ax 2017-18
and i think it was 18. yeah it was like
two years ago i think yeah yeah
so we were drinking in it and i
obviously had to go to the bathroom and
they only had one bathroom
in the place this was the funimation
party i didn't know if you mentioned it
i did mention that okay so i went in and
then i
i see this guy just laying on the
[ __ ] floor in there and i was like
i kind of get up and i wait so what was
he in like the women's toilet there was
only one toilet
oh okay and um he's just like face down
i thought he was dead like i thought
something like he over drank or he was
like dead or something because he was
face down in the middle of the toilet
and he wasn't moving and i kept waking
him up and then i just like i kind of
like kept shaking him and then he's just
like i realized cause he starts speaking
japanese he's a japanese guy right
yeah and then um
he's just like in the most like really
broken english he's like i'm one of the
animators for boca no hero i'm like
can you get the [ __ ] out of the bathroom
i don't care who you are i need a piss
when can i see you again i'm like who
the [ __ ]
he's like he just told you
because the guests are like some of the
animators from boko no hero were there
and he's just like there he's like i'm
like did you are you okay
like can you just get out i had to take
a piss dude and he's just like
can i see you again i'm like just get
the [ __ ] out
i but he was like i felt bad because
he's like obviously really wasted
hey man we all have we all yeah we've
we've all been there we've all been
there
yeah more than once so yeah um i think
we've told enough stories
for a lifetime is there anything you
want to like shout out
i guess on your side of things because
you are you are technically a guest
yeah i'm sure yeah even though we know
we see each other
promote promote your [ __ ] please
subscribe to sitsnap
and uh what a marketing genius
[Laughter]
if you wanna if you want to check out
sydney's stuff those stuff is in the
description check the link in the
description i'll shout out
you can check out sydney at
twitter.comsnap and man
[Music]
check out the description you [ __ ]
yes it's all it's all in the description
hey but also
thank you to our patrons for supporting
the show as always look at all these
lovely
names look at all these lovelies the
most beautiful names yeah i love them so
much
of course this guy this guy enjoys the
plot i know he does i watch
all these guys but if you like to
support the show then as always go to
patreon.com exactly and help us
create some more cool content also make
sure to uh check out our twitter and
subreddit as always that is also in the
description below
and hey you're probably wondering about
the shirts that we're all wearing yes we
did mention this last time but this is
your last
week to get it you can click click in
the link description or go to joey i
forgot the url
please take over trash taste buy it now
they won't be
here again so get it now while you still
can but by the time by the time the next
episode comes out these shirts will be
unavailable and they're probably not
going to come back so if you'd like to
grab them limited edition stuff
edition trash t-shirt first edition
trash test go check it out
again thank you very much sydney for
joining us today you're so bloody
welcome
oh my god all right okay
that's the end bye
[Music]
you